[Musique]
Christophe de Loire bonjour bonjour nous
vous recevons pour une chaîne internet
qui s'appelle thinkerview nous sommes en
direct est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succinctement
je suis un ancien journaliste
d'investigation qui est travaillé sur
des sujets très différents
principalement au magazine Le Point j'ai
aussi un peu travaillé en télévision et
je suis depuis bientôt 10 ans le
secrétaire général et le directeur
général de Reporters sans frontières RSF
de l'organisation internationale et
depuis moins longtemps le président du
Forum sur la formation à la démocratie
qui est une structure que nous avons
créé mais on y reviendra peut-être plus
tard
on a décidé de vous faire revenir ce
soir parce que journalistiquement
parlant il y a plein de choses qui se
passent et parce que aussi vous avez
créé un bouquin sur les questions de
surveillance de numérique de capitalisme
de surveillance tout un tas de choses
qui sont
connectés avec notre monde et le monde
journalistique
première question c'est pourquoi vous
intéresser à ça que maintenant ou
peut-être faire un bouquin que
maintenant là-dessus oui parce que j'ai
commencé à m'y intéresser avant de faire
le bouquin heureusement oui il vaut
mieux faire les choses dans ce sens là
j'étais donc en arrivant à reportage on
va parler aussi du crâne bien sûr
protection des journalistes c'est la
moindre des choses des journalistes sous
les balles ce qui se passe en temps de
guerre mais on va faire quelques petits
bons sauter du coq à l'âne comme on fait
d'habitude je te redonne la parole
j'essaierai de rebondir avec la balle
je suis arrivé à reporter sans
frontières
et puis on défend les journalistes
partout dans le monde et on défend des
journalistes qui incarnent nos idéaux
faire des gens qui ont franchement du
courage qui sont des gens qui ont
scrupules très profonds pour la vérité
font souvent des règles éthiques solides
on choisit vraiment de défendre si je
peux commencer par une métaphore
sportive mais les meilleurs joueurs et
ses meilleurs joueurs dans beaucoup de
pays par définition c'est ceux qui sont
les plus attaqués
et on le fait un peu partout dans le
monde on a des correspondants dans 130
pays on a beaucoup peut-être on y
viendra plus tard mais on a beaucoup
travaillé sur nos modes d'action parce
que il y avait un moment où rapportent
sans frontières essentiellement était
dans la stratégie qu'on appelle en
anglais du nameing and shaming dénoncer
et faire honte en gros utiliser la
proclamation publique pour faire
pression ce qui marchait
autrefois si mais c'est une logique qui
est assez commune dans les organisations
de droits de l'homme
la pression médiatique sur certains
régimes peut être utile à les faire
prendre des meilleures décisions ou à
libérer tel ou tel ça marche de moins en
moins bien en tout cas il faut pas faire
que ça français pardon ça marche sur le
régime français ça marche d'une certaine
manière ça marche peut-être mieux dans
les démocraties dans les dictatures mais
la montée en puissance sur le plan
géopolitique des régimes d'esthétiques
des régimes autoritaires fait que
disons-le l'intimidation de la pression
médiatique
occidentale ou des démocraties elle est
de moins en moins opérante et donc il
faut trouver de nouveaux modes d'action
mais même si j'essaie de rebondir je
reviens j'essaie de prendre le fil donc
on défend on défend des joueurs en
inventant des nouveaux modes d'action
et puis on s'est dit mais en fait ces
joueurs
ils sont certains portants mais s'ils
sont victimes ou si le travail qu'ils
font le journalisme et
peut être fragilisée c'est parce qu'il y
a des règles du jeu
et que ces règles du jeu elles sont
suffisamment importantes pour qu'on s'y
intéresse et que les règles du jeu elles
dépassent le journalisme parce que c'est
les règles du jeu c'est l'organisation
de la délibération publique de la
communication entre les gens les êtres
humains ou dans des groupes sociaux ou
dans des nations dans des pays et donc
essayons de s'intéresser aux règles du
jeu dans ce qui est aujourd'hui le champ
de l'information et le champ de
l'information ça n'est plus que les
journaux ça n'est pas seulement les
journalistes
il y a une époque où c'était beaucoup
eux ou le journaliste avait une forme de
monopole de filtrage
le filtrage il est pas nécessairement
illégitime j'ai vu que tu avais
les paupières qui a les sourciller
c'est pas nécessairement illégitime le
filtrage la médiation elle est pas
absurde on y reviendra peut-être plus
tard mais
au fond à l'époque ce qui était
important c'était que les journalistes
soient le plus honnêtes les plus gros la
plus grande qualité etc qui a un plus
grand pluralisme et mais là maintenant
le champ de l'information il inclut
rien à voir les uns avec les autres et
qui sont tous en concurrence directe et
ça c'est inédit dans l'histoire
démocratie enfin c'est inédit dans
l'histoire de la communication d'une
certaine donc elle a propagande d'État
la publicité
le journalisme de qualité ou de moins
bonne qualité les conversations à la
table du dimanche les conversations
privées la chanson sous la douche les
uns de l'autobi de l'automobiliste à son
volant mais maintenant sur le numérique
tout ça en concurrence directe et
surtout
derrière et c'est ça la matrice il y a
quand même des gens qui organisent tout
ça
c'est un système la matrice c'est un
système invisible c'est une
infrastructure il y a quelqu'un qu'on
définit les lois et ces personnes là
avant vous pouvez leur faire beaucoup de
reproches on les connaissait c'était les
représentants c'était les élus c'était
le Parlement maintenant c'est plus le
Parlement
des lois qui avons été adoptées par les
parlements sont concrètement aujourd'hui
adoptés par des pouvoirs
des pouvoirs privés
les gafams
équivalent chinois les béatx et par
parfois des dictateurs
et donc on a c'est comme si on avait
remis les clés des démocraties
quand je dis les lois sont adoptées il y
a ce fameux dicton que chacun dans ta
communauté doit connaître
c'est la loi mais c'est vrai au sens
propre et le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui la loi c'est plus les
parlements c'est plus les institutions
démocratiques qui les font
c'est plus les institutions
démocratiques ça n'est plus la justice
qui les interprète c'est les mêmes que
ceux qui les addict à savoir les
plateformes numériques dans le meilleur
des cas quand ça n'est pas des systèmes
autoritaires
et ça n'est pas eux qui dans cet espace
prennent des visions même un caractère
financier d'attribution c'est encore les
pouvoirs privés et donc
cette matrice elle a remplacé les
institutions démocratiques et la
remplacé le cadre démocratique et
l'objet du bouquin c'est d'en reprendre
le contrôle technique Bac control comme
disent les Anglais alors on va cuisiner
un peu
tu parlais on va poser déjà une question
sur quel est ton point de vue sur ta
profession on a décidé à chaque fois
qu'on recevait un journaliste on lui
reposant la question à chaque fois
est-ce que tu as un point de vue
critique est-ce que tu es fier de ta
profession pourquoi ta profession
est-elle malade
qu'est-ce qui se passe le pourquoi le
comment et ensuite on va délayer ça pour
en arriver à pourquoi les journalistes
se prennent des balles
et ensuite pourquoi les journalistes se
font flipper pourquoi les journalistes
se font infecter leur téléphone avec des
logiciels qui pourraient les écouter
exfiltrer leurs informations et voilà un
jour j'étais venu de voir il y a très
longtemps avec je me souviens de mes
potes et on avait comme projet de 15
minutes de vie privée pour les
journalistes ça te rappelle quelque
chose on en avait reparlé la première
fois où je suis venu ça fait des années
et on est encore sur le même sujet
quel point de vue tu as sur ta
profession
je vais être mesuré
la mesure c'est pas interdit ici
d'abord il y a une chose il y a deux
choses différentes c'est la profession
telle qu'on peut idéalement la concevoir
l'idéal du journaliste il y a la réalité
du journaliste qui est très multiple
parce que soyons clairs journalistes ils
sont en fonction des pays en fonction
des rédactions c'est
il y a le jour et la nuit
c'est c'est pas une profession purement
homogène même s'il peut y avoir une
critique de conformisme qui est parfois
tout à fait légitime et donc moi je
crois fondamentalement
pour être honnête je ne sais pas ce que
sera le journaliste dans 10 20 ou 30 ans
on ne peut même pas exclure
effectivement que le journaliste tel
qu'on soit aujourd'hui a été une
parenthèse historique assez courte
ce que le journaliste peut-elle qu'on
soit aujourd'hui
au fond il a été inventé à la fin du 19e
siècle donc c'est pas si longtemps avant
il y avait des publics
alors précisément c'était un moment où
il y avait une confusion entre l'action
politique et le journalisme et qu'on
appelait les publicités et d'ailleurs la
première liberté de la presse elle a été
inventée à ce moment-là et puis à la fin
du 19e siècle il y a eu la construction
de l'éthique du journalisme et de la
professionnalisation du journalisme et
alors ça a commencé aux États-Unis
notamment avec l'édiction de la première
charte de déontologie de la Society of
professional journaliste j'imagine que
tu fermes interroger plus tard sur la
charte de Munich qui est la question non
non faut pas trop oui
et la création dans le Missouri la
première école de journalisme et puis en
France c'est justement de l'affaire
Dreyfus qui est créé la première école
de journées est-ce que l'école
supérieure de journaliste de Paris
et puis au fil de l'histoire se
construisent se développe l'éthique etc
et souvent la faveur des conflits
et d'ailleurs là on est à un moment avec
la garant de crâne un conflit ou
peut-être ça va amener à faire prendre
conscience de choses qui fait qu'on va
réintroduire des règles qui n'existaient
pas parce que un monde de la
communication totalement déréglée c'est
un monde qui peut mener ou guerre le
journalisme par exemple
[Musique]
un métier que j'aime mais a pu en
fonction de son exercice mener à des
catastrophes la guerre de 14
c'est une guerre qui a largement été
préparée par les journalistes les
journaux de l'époque dans les différents
pays qui ont enflammé les esprits et
c'est par hasard c'est en 1918 qui a été
adopté la première charte
déontologie des journalistes en France
qui est la Sarthe du SNJ du Syndicat
national des gens est-ce que tu es revu
après
c'est par hasard si c'est à la fin de la
seconde après la Seconde Guerre mondiale
à la faveur du programme du Conseil
National de la Résistance
adopter un nouveau cadre de régulation
des médias
à la même époque aux États-Unis la FC et
l'équivalent de l'organe de régulation
un store une doctrine s'appelle la
Fernandez doctrine sur
qui est de baleines d'équilibre doctrine
américaine qui permet d'avoir des médias
non polarisants et des décennies plus
tard Reagan va démanteler tout ça cette
fermette doctrine va tomber
Fox News sera créé
ça entraînera une polarisation
à droite mais aussi à gauche des médias
américains puis une polarisation de la
société qui est dans un état de quasi
implosion explosion
et donc
voilà cette histoire j'ai fini quand
même par perdre le fil ta question
c'était ton esprit critique sur les
journalistes donc les donc la fonction
sociale des moi je pense que ce qui
perdurera en tout cas c'est la fonction
sociale du journal et ça je pense
qu'aucune vie n'est possible ni en tant
que citoyen capteur social économique
c'est d'être des tiers de confiance des
sociétés c'est à dire que les procédures
journalistiques qui sont garanties par
des méthodes une méthodologie par des
règles éthiques par un cadre
d'indépendance éditoriale et par des
formes de transparence tout ça ça nous
permet à nous à chacun d'entre nous de
d'assurer notre droit à l'information et
si j'ai pas des informations fiables qui
me parviennent alors je suis l'aisé à
tout point de vue je suis les ai en tant
que citoyen dans une démocratie qui peut
pas voter sur la base de fait je suis
pas un être humain qui peut sécuriser sa
survie
où sa santé et ça on s'en est tous
rendus compte au moment du covid si je
suis floué sur l'information qu'on en
voit c'est ma survie biologique qui est
en danger même chose en tant qu'acteur
économique
en tant qu'intervenant sur un marché par
exemple donc à tout point de vue on a
besoin qu'il y a une fonction sociale on
peut pas se dire et aujourd'hui les
plateformes numériques les saperçu que
il suffit qu'on mette tout et puis on
verra bien les gens distant vont bien le
vrai du faux et ça c'est pas vrai ça
peut pas se passer comme ça
ça peut se comprendre je me fais
l'avocat du diable
si tout est disponible
les Gafa font confiance au système
éducatif des sociétés pour apprendre aux
gens à trier le bon de commencer quoi
l'expression le bon du livre le bon
grain le bon grain de livret
est-ce qu'il y a aussi une connexion
entre le système éducatif vacillant
et profession journalistique vacillante
et ce combo des deux laisse le champ
ouvert à toute forme de propagande
en fait l'idée que l'éducation fait tout
moi je suis d'enseignant instituteurs je
suis j'ai dirigé une école de
journalisme le Centre de Formation des
Journalistes à Paris
l'éducation l'enseignement je suis très
attaché en revanche je pense qu'il faut
pas lui demander trop et en matière de
débat public de conversation
l'enjeu c'est plus le système le système
de de l'espace public cette matrice
aujourd'hui que de dire il faut que vous
soyez formé par exemple à l'éducation
aux médias aujourd'hui on en parle
beaucoup d'éducation médias évidemment
c'est utile évidemment c'est bien mais
laissez à penser que parce qu'on est
éduqué aux médias on s'est distingué
cette photo
elle est vraie ou fausse si elle était
bien prise à l'endroit où prétend le
jour où prétend et si l'interprétation
est la bonne c'est pas vrai la personne
la plus éduquée aux médias au monde sur
le présente une photo ça ne dit rien de
la vérité on est on est obligé de
déléguer notre confiance on est obligé
de déléguer notre confiance à quelqu'un
dont une fonction à plein temps ou pas
mais mais qui nous prouve qu'elle fait
des recherches qui nous permettent
d'avoir une présomption de véracité et
donc cette fonction que moi j'appelle de
tiers de confiance des sociétés pour
l'ensemble des champs je disais santé
économique sociale politique
elle va perdurer et ça c'est ça qu'il
faut sécuriser
je sais pas de je sais pas s'il y a déjà
des commentaires disant voilà il veut
pas répondre à la question je vais y
répondre à la question mais j'arrive
mais tu en as posé une autre entre-temps
et tu m'empêche de répondre à ta propre
question c'était quoi
la nouvelle non alors la précédente ce
que je pense c'est que évidemment cette
fonction
elle est pas toujours
exercée à la hauteur de l'idéal
moi ce que je perçois en France et tu
sais chaque année il y a le sondage dans
la croix le baromètre sur la confiance
dans les médias et cette année pour la
première fois j'ai participé à la
conférence de presse donc je me suis
vraiment penché sur les chiffres et
chaque année on se lamente en disant oh
là là les gens en France pas la liberté
de la presse et la confiance dans les
journalistes les gens et alors moi c'est
marrant mais j'en ai tiré quelque chose
de positif pourquoi parce que si on
regarde bien les Français critiques les
journalistes au nom de l'idéal du
journalisme et ça c'est positif c'est à
dire qu'on dit vous n'êtes pas
indépendant parce qu'on veut que vous
soyez indépendant et qu'on croit
l'indépendance éditoriale
vous nous donnez des leçons mais parce
qu'on veut que vous nous apportiez des
faits pas que vous ne donniez des leçons
on veut
et donc au fond
dans la population française enfin la
lumière de sondage en tout cas
on voit qu'il y a une aspiration un
journal alors les journalistes pourquoi
ils sont
quand même la confiance des pas à des
niveaux extrêmement élevés et même quand
on regarde par rapport à d'autres
professions
[Musique]
les gens ils sont plutôt vers le bas
journaliste
sont pas dans les sondages mais
les gens arrivent même assez loin après
des institutions démocratiques mais
avant les réseaux sociaux en termes
informationnel d'ailleurs les
journalistes arrivent quand même avant
les autres faut le et
il y a plusieurs choses qu'on leur
reproche et moi je pense en partie
légitime
parfois leur manque de rigueur
et c'est vrai qu'une faute moi j'ai
dirigé une école de journalisme dont le
fondateur disait une faute alors je sais
plus comment il utilise l'expression
mais je me fais je me prendrais pour une
erreur
parce que selon la phrase utilisée par
l'un de tes invités précédents enfin pas
ici mais
Jean-Claude Mélenchon Mélenchon Jean-Luc
Jean-Luc j'étais Jean-Luc Mélenchon
il y a une forme de caricature morale
c'est à dire que dès lors qu'un
journaliste à la prétention de te dire
quoi penser et de te dire où est le bien
où est le mal
ça rend la confiance parce que les
journalistes peuvent avoir une valeur
ajoutée qui est d'aller voir sur place
d'avoir enquêté d'avoir jugé les pièces
et ça ça a de la valeur
mais ça me donne pas le droit en tant
que journaliste de dire ce qu'il faut
penser ce qu'il faut voter
si telle personne est mal et ça ça roule
la confiance il y a d'autres qui fait
référence à la une de tous les journaux
genre voté Macron et des choses comme ça
non j'ai pas lu exactement ça mais tu me
diras sur quel journal tu as vu ça mais
ça fait référence de manière générale à
mais au-delà de pendant longtemps par
exemple il y a eu des choses qui étaient
totalement interdites dans le débat
public totalement ou quasi totalement le
plus grand tabou alors et à droite comme
à gauche ce n'est pas qu'une histoire
généralement les gens de droite disent
que c'est l'autre qui pose un tabou mais
où chacun
il y avait la question de l'immigration
qui quand même très vite était invalidé
alors qu'elle était posée
il y avait la question du libre-échange
et du protectionnisme
c'est plus large et moi je l'ai vécu
j'ai vécu un moment je me souviens quand
Villepin était premier ministre
il avait voulu il défendait une idée de
protectionnisme européen sous
l'influence d'Emmanuel Todd
et moi je suis assez copain avec Toad et
par ailleurs en tant que journaliste
c'est pas en tant que copinage je me
disais quand même il y a un sujet si tu
n'es pas où il y avait un prix Nobel qui
s'appelait français qui était Maurice
Allais
alors qui était un peu excentrique mais
qui n'avait plus accès aux médias parce
que certains le trouvaient trop
excentriques mais aussi parce qu'il
défendaient les idées qui n'étaient pas
en cours
qu'il est d'une certaine manière pas
droit de citer
et
c'était impossible de passer une
interview sur ce sujet là
et pas seulement dans la presse de
droite encore plus dans la prise de
gauche et donc
ça ça alors ensuite ça a pu mener à
c'est vrai qu'au moment des deux
référendum Maastricht est traité
constitutionnelle européen le côté
vous êtes des blaireaux si vous votez
pas ça
ou des racistes ou des machins ou des
voilà ou des racistes ou des beaux fous
tout ça ça
ça ça coupe la confiance et il faut
qu'on se remette de ça
il faut qu'on se remette malheureusement
aux États-Unis
la confiance ça se construit
petit à petit
le vieil adage c'est la confiance mais
des années à être construite et se perd
en deux minutes c'est ça
je connais pas mais en tout cas il y a
l'image du Petit Prince qui dit pour
avoir la confiance assis-toi là-bas puis
après toi chaque jour tu t'acieras un
peu plus près
il faut chaque jour ça soit un peu plus
près et moi je au moment où Trump parce
que malheureusement les États-Unis
parfois on vingt ans d'avance sur nous
dans la bêtise ah mais j'ai pas dit que
et
au moment où Trump était élu les
journaux de la côte ouest disent on va
les revoir le pays on va aller on va
faire le travail qu'on n'a pas fait
avant on va essayer de le comprendre
notre propre pays on va aller voir et
malheureusement très vite il suffisait
d'aller ouvrir des grands journaux de la
côte ouest et on voyait que des pages
sur Trump sur Trump sur Trump pas sur
les électeurs de Trump ils allaient pas
au fond du ministre à avoir comment ça
se passait et ça
des journalistes en surplomb
qui expliquent quoi penser
moi il y a un gars alors
on y reviendra ça mais si tu veux mais
il y a d'autres choses qui sont à mon
sens facteur de défiance et moi il y en
a une un jour il y a un village il y a
un camarade de mon village qui me dit
moi je lis les journaux pour une raison
ton visage à moi ça s'appelle Molinet
dans le département de l'Allier
au nord de l'Auvergne enfin maintenant
et
il y a un de mes camarades qui me dit
c'est tout le temps négatif
vous voyez les journalistes la réalité
que par le négatif
et c'est vrai
enfin le que il faut
évidemment qu'il y a des choses parfois
positives mais c'est vrai que il y a
certains
aspects de la doctrine joint ici si je
puis dire dans certaines cultures
journalistiques
qui ont des effets alors en termes de
confiance et le question sur la
démocratie qui peuvent être négatifs et
le fait on a tous des biais cognitifs
qui fait que
on a une préférence pour le négatif
c'est ce qui fait que les gens la
machine à café ont souvent tendance à
dire du mal de leurs collègues plutôt
que du bien
et
en fait
dans les démocraties ça amène à toujours
à
je dis dans les démocraties parce que
malheureusement enfin
d'une certaine manière le contrôle de
l'information amène à des espèces de
d'élan et de qui fait qu'il y a une
forme de projection
y compris dans les dictatures qui peut
plaire je suis vraiment pas en train de
favoriser le modèle dictatoriaux ou de
les justifier enfin ou de les justifier
au contraire je lutte contre mais qui
donne une espèce de souffle
et d'ailleurs il y a un sondage qui est
hallucinant qui est un sondage fait par
la société Edelman et dolman trust
barrette où on pose la question aux gens
dans quel pays vous faites le plus
confiance aux médias un jour j'ai
assisté une séance et on se retrouve et
je te le donne quel est le pays où la
confiance et la plus forte
la Chine alors bon les gars ils ont
peut-être pas
toutes l'attitude pour répondre et se
méfie peut-être en se disant il y a
peut-être un gars du Parti communiste
derrière le l'interviewer mais néanmoins
il y a un symptôme qu'il faut regarder
et
cette négativité elle a un vrai défaut
c'est qu'elle nous empêche de voir la
réalité du monde parce que si on ne juge
que par les en fait c'est normal je
disais on a tous des biais cognitifs
le
négatif fait vendre
moins un jour j'ai parlé à mon ancien
éditeur et j'ai voulu je lui ai dit moi
je veux plus faire ce genre de bouquin
où on ne fait que du négatif où on a
d'abord ça il m'a répondu et au coco
mais Christophe on vit là dessus
et donc il y a un effet de système de
marché qui fait qu'il y a une préférence
pour négative et qui nous empêche de
voir la réalité de l'évolution du monde
par exemple si on demande aux Français
sur certains sondages est-ce que le
monde va mieux
on a 3 % des Français qui disent que le
monde va de mieux en mieux
et pourtant
on a un peu plus d'un siècle l'espérance
de vie est passé de 30 à 70 ans 71 ans
je crois dans le monde
quel prix l'espérance de vie est passée
de 30 à 71 ans
les conflits quoi qu'on pense sont moins
meurtriers qu'ils ne le furent
la
30 ans la mortalité infantile la
mortalité maternelle a été divisée par
deux
2 milliards de personnes je crois sont
sortis de la sous-alimentation
il y a même un économiste allemand qui a
fait un truc assez intéressant
qui a dit qui a fait des calculs et qui
a établit un fait que les médias
auraient pu rapporter chaque jour alors
bon ça aurait été chiant de faire la
même une chaque jour mais chaque jour
c'est une réalité
hier c'est vrai depuis 30 ans chaque
jour depuis 30 ans hier 137000 personnes
sont sorties de l'extrême pauvreté
alors tu peux dire à quel prix mais
137000 personnes sont sorties de
l'extrême pauvreté c'est pas mal quand
même
et ça je suis pas certain que quand on
regarde
un certain nombre de média on le voit
vraiment que ça nous aide à en prendre
conscience et donc moi si je raconte ça
c'est parce que je pense qu'il faut
s'interroger là-dessus parce que
moi j'ai assisté à une conférence à un
jour c'était vraiment d'un
danois qui est dirigé l'audiovisuel
public danois qui s'appelle oulric à
aguru puis qui a créé un institut à
l'université d'arus au Danemark qui
s'appelle le constructive institut et
lui défend le constructif journalisme
kebab du tout l'idée selon laquelle il
faudrait juste apporter des solutions
faire du journalisme à l'eau de rose
mais lutter contre le biais de
négativité
et qui montrait et c'était dans une
conférence où il y avait 80 agences de
presse les 80 plus grandes agences de
presse du monde ils leur montrait
regardé j'ai sur vos sites et le
pourcentage de négativité et
je pense que c'est ça ça fait partie des
fondamentaux du journaliste parce que
il y a plein de gens qui considèrent que
notre devoir c'est juste de montrer ce
qui va pas de montrer qu'il est pas à
l'heure de montrer ce qui se passe non
non mais ce qui se passe
et c'est tout le cœur du sujet ce qui se
passe ça n'est pas que l'événementiel
si on considère que ce qui se passe
c'est d'abord les accidents et les
catastrophes
[Musique]
non mais même ça peut être l'accident de
car
la catastrophe enfin le glissement de
terrain le
l'assassinat le
en fait si on regarde le monde sous cet
angle et juste sous cet angle si on ne
regarde que les événements les
événements par nature ils sont négatifs
il est rare que un phénomène positif ça
soit par d'un seul coup on monte une
marche
en fait
on tombe d'une marche et donc c'est
extrêmement important de regarder aussi
les situations et leurs évolutions et
d'arriver à avoir un regard sur le monde
qui ne soit pas simplement sous un angle
qui ne nous est pas toujours très
profitable à titre individuel qui peut
nous plomber et qui ne nous est pas très
profitable non plus à titre collectif
qui peut plomber nos démocraties
voilà alors après je peux faire plein
d'autres critiques sur le conformisme
mais ça j'en ai un peu plus parlé sur
alors ça revient même il peut alors même
si les deux logis les choses sont un peu
en train de changer d'abord
c'est-à-dire honnêtement tous les gens
les Français n'ont pas la même idée
plutôt en train de s'élargir en ce
moment
par rapport à ce que ce qu'on a connu il
y a 20 ans ou 30 ans il y a quand même
après on peut trouver que dans tel ou
tel média il y a une idéologie dominante
ça oui
que veut dire ce silence
en train de me poser la question de
est-ce qu'on va réussir à inverser la
vapeur on a sélectionné des journalistes
depuis des années avec des écoles de
journalistes qui les ont sélectionnés
maintenant ces journalistes ont un peu
grandi ils ont acquis des postes pour
ceux qui ne sont pas encore au chômage
ou en précarité grandissante est-ce que
ces journalistes vont réussir à penser
contre eux-mêmes est-ce que le fossé
n'est pas trop dur à combler tout de
suite alors que les événements
s'accélèrent en termes de stabilité
sociale en termes de consommation
énergétique en termes de consommation en
matière première et et en termes de
déliquer sans société est-ce que il faut
faire un il faut tous les virer et
prendre des nouveaux
est-ce qu'il faut qui a un conseil de
surveillance du journaliste pour dire
voilà là vous avez dépassé les bornes
parce que vous n'avez pas été
suffisamment équilibré ou là on a trop
senti que vous étiez idéologiquement
investi dedans
où ils ont oublié de penser contre
eux-mêmes est-ce que c'est pas
trop tard quand on voit quand on voit
que le réchauffement climatique va nous
ravager que les matières premières sont
en
chute libre les prix augmentent
drastiquement que le taux d'énervement
des des gens dans les sociétés est en
train d'augmenter
est-ce que la voie journalistique va
pouvoir se faire écouter pour apaiser
tout ça pour donner de l'information
pour que les gens puissent agir en âme
et conscience ou est-ce que c'est
maintenant c'est 21e siècle un fauteuil
meurt il faut qu'il y ait des lumières
partout il faut que ça cligne il faut
que ce soit hype c'est pas trop tu
comprends ce que je dis ou pas
jusque là j'arrive à comprendre
la question c'était est-ce que je
m'exprime suffisamment bien sûr
bon là j'ai fait la critique du
journaliste et j'aurais pu aller plus
loin je pense plus continuer non mais je
ne peux pas faire que ça
mais il y a plein d'autres biais
un biais de disponibilité qui fait que
si il y a 20 ans j'ai raconté un truc
sur toi je le ressors 20 ans plus tard
parce que c'est ce qui m'a marqué et ça
ça sur les personnalités par exemple
tout le temps tu donc elles peuvent
avoir des une phrase malheureuse à un
moment qui a pris une seconde de leur
vie et ça reste comme un scotch
et c'est utilisé et ça fait que voilà il
y a le biais de disputé il y a un billet
de enfin il y a toutes sortes de bière
il y a du spectateur que c'est plus
facile d'être un spectateur que
quelqu'un qui agit et
il y a des formes de corruption
ou d'influence sociologique
bon il y en a plein
après j'ai commencé par négatif tout est
pas acheté
et quand même à tous ceux qui
vilipendent les gens et sa longueur de
journée il y a la des centaines et des
centaines de gens qui font leur boulot
qu'en quête qui sont curieux et qui
parfois se font enfin qui font bien leur
boulot qui sont indépendants qui et qui
sont pourrir la gueule par des gens de
mauvaise foi qui ont rien vérifié et qui
juste ont des certitudes donc souvent
des journalistes
mais parfois du public aussi et le
public assez concrètement
sans faire on n'est pas là pour faire un
exposé de sociologie politique mais le
journalisme l'espace public à ces
problèmes
le public lui-même a ses problèmes et là
c'est contradictions il a ses
contradictions parce que quand vous êtes
journaliste vous apercevez que si vous
faites un truc
un type à droite vous critique pour être
trop à gauche à gauche vous critique
trop à droite vous avez des accusations
contradictoires
que les gens qui sont jamais allés voir
ce qui se passait à Bagdad vont vous
dire que c'est pas vrai ce que vous avez
dit
que
quoi vous disiez au fond et quel que
soit votre honnêteté vous allez vous
faire courir la gueule et
que finalement le journaliste ressemble
beaucoup au public
alors il y a une alors
en revanche
et même le public le reproche de trop
lui ressembler par exemple dans le
sondage la croix que shittait l'une des
principales critiques et ça renvoie un
truc tu viens de dire c'est
vous cherchez trop l'audience
me chercher l'audience c'est chercher le
public
et journalistes qui cherchent à faire de
l'audience ces journalistes qui
cherchent à satisfaire les envies les
besoins les demandes du public c'est une
phrase très très connue ça ne donnez pas
aux gens ce que tu veux mais donner
l'heure ce qu'ils veulent oui mais c'est
le public
mais ça c'est un problème et moi je vois
quand même beaucoup de journalistes qui
veulent couvrir des sujets que je
qualifierais noble je me souviens de
l'époque un grand porteur
du étranger de libération à qui j'ai
posé la question c'est quoi pour vous le
plus grand problème de liberté de la
presse et humain a répondu c'est le
public il en a rien à [__] de ce que
je veux faire
alors que moi j'ai envie d'aller
raconter ce qui se passe là-bas en Syrie
et donc
l'enjeu pour sauver tout ça c'est pas de
dire remplacer les tous
dégager les
peut-être quelques personnes
ça fera du bien mais de manière générale
non d'abord parce qu'il y a un
savoir-faire qu'il faut conserver
ensuite parce que
moi j'ai pu l'observer
parfois vous avez des rédactions où il y
a une
identité très forte vous mettez j’étais
directeur du code journaliste je l'ai vu
prenez quelqu'un qui ressemble pas du
tout
jetez dans une rédaction qui ressemble à
ça trois mois plus tard il ressemble à
cette rédaction même s'il était très
différent à l'origine mais ça c'est le
principe du flic ça c'est le principe du
flic
d'extrême droite qu'on met qu'on faisait
infiltrer un réseau trots et qui devait
être ce qui est tout l'inverse
et donc l'enjeu celle-ci c'est d'abord
les effets de système et il y a pas
besoin d'être marxiste pour dire que les
effets de système l'emportent sur les
questions de personnes
comment est construit le marché de
l'information et ça finalement on s'y
intéresse à ses peu alors que c'est le
sujet tu crois pas du tout
l'incorruptiabilité
l'incorruptibilité merci
les inconruptibles chez les journalistes
ça existe des mecs qui pensent contre
eux toute la journée des ça existe
encore oui mais parfois c'est de plus en
plus rare mais il suffit pas de penser
contre toi-même la question c'est
comment tu agis et moi j'adore la phrase
pour danser contre soi-même la phrase de
Charles Péguy
il y en a une autre de Bergson qui est
pas mal qui est que quand on fait du
vélo dans la rue faut aussi être sur le
balcon à se regarder et faire du vélo
il faut arriver à penser des deux
manières mais
la question c'est qu'est-ce que à la fin
le débouché ce qui crée le la production
de l'information c'est un cas de
juridique
des moyens économiques
une culture et à la fin des personnes et
donc si tu ne touches qu'aux personnes
en fait tu changes rien je pense que
c'est vrai dans d'autres secteurs que
dans celui-là mais c'est celui que je
connais le mieux mais celui-là ça suffit
pas et donc à la fin si ce qui est en
jeu si la pression concurrentielle
fait que pour la survie économique de
l'entreprise de médias
on décide d'aller faire certaines types
de sujet tu peux avoir des personnes qui
disent non non moi je pense qu'il
faudrait faire autre chose
mais généralement quand on parle de ces
sujets-là et ça je pense que c'est
l'erreur de chacun c'est ce qu'on adore
dire c'est on adore critiquer les
symptômes plutôt que s'intéresser aux
causes et tu parlais tout à l'heure du
réchauffement climatique c'est comme
pour le réchauffement climatique
traiter des symptômes ça sert à rien
vaut mieux traiter les causes
et les causes ça allait regarder
l'organisation le système d'organisation
et lui il a toujours existé et par
exemple sur ces questions là on est
beaucoup quand on parle entre amis en
famille les questions c'est beaucoup
qu'est-ce qu'on a le droit de dire
mais ça en fait c'est assez que
secondaire d'abord parce que il y a des
restrictions raisonnables en droit des
choses qui échappent à la liberté
d'expression et avant il y avait la
justice qui ont décidé et puis
maintenant c'est plus la justice qu'en
disside c'est les plateformes c'est les
algorithmes et puis il y a toute
l'organisation de ce qui est licite
de mentir
félicite de raconter quelque chose dont
on a aucune idée si c'est vrai ou faux
les rumeurs c'est les sites de faire de
la publicité
c'est ici de mais au fil de l'histoire
les démocraties elles ont instauré un
système et qui n'était pas parfait ça
jamais été parfait franchement
je suis pas con au point d'avoir oublié
qu'il y a eu l'ORTF qui a eu
qui a eu des formes de corruption etc
mais
ce qui est
j'en perd le fil
mais il y avait on a établi des
garanties quand même pour qu'il y ait
des essayer d'assurer le plus possible
d'indépendance éditorial le plus
possible de pluralisme le plus possible
de rigueur et ça ça a été balayé par les
plateformes numériques plein d'avantages
parce que ça a ouvert la communication
parce qu'il y avait des formes de
domination
de domination dans l'espace
lié à des capacités financières qu'on
peut totalement disparu évidemment que
le fait que 9 milliardaires possède une
bonne partie de la presse privée privée
en
parfois on préfère parce que il y a des
rédactions qui vont dire s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît acheter nous sinon on va
mourir
ils sont pas tous ils ont pas tous
exactement les mêmes pratiques mais
quand même on peut pas dire que ça n'a
pas d'influence ne serait-ce que sur
qu'est-ce qui a acceptable en termes de
lignes éditoriale
évidemment que ça a une influence et si
c'était
au lieu d'avoir 9 hommes d'affaires
milliardaires il y avait 9 blogueurs
neufs dentistes neuf enseignants ça
serait pas exactement les mêmes médias
et
donc notre question aujourd'hui qu'on
doit se poser c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on veut comme droit à
l'information et comme on le sécurise et
comment on sécurise ça suppose dans
s'intéresser à des choses auxquelles
généralement s'intéresse pas je peux pas
il y avait une loi qui a été adoptée à
la Libération sur la presse écrite qui
s'appelle la loi bichette qui a été revu
récemment qui garantit le pluralisme sur
le numérique elle n'existe pas comment
on fait
et ça c'est tous les sujets sur lesquels
on s'est mis à travailler sur la matrice
est-ce que tu as détecté un prisme de
lecture ou une volonté d'aller à gauche
à droite ou de polariser les gens est-ce
que tu as détecté quelque chose d'une
volonté derrière tout ça ou c'est
simplement
il y a deux choses il y a parfois des
effets non voulus Twitter par exemple
s'est rendu compte avait la considéré
que son algorithme était neutre et s'est
rendu compte que ça favorisait des
positions très à droite
ils ont du mal à comprendre ça
mais il y a aussi le risque de ministère
de la Vérité et moi j'aime pas trop
généralement l'expression ministère de
la maladie parce que je trouve que vous
allez employer c'est un peu le point
Goodwin
à 1984 de George well situation dans
laquelle on se retrouve un peu en ce
moment
mais les plateformes numériques
aujourd'hui elles ont de pouvoir
l'exerce pas toujours mais elles ont le
pouvoir du ministère de la Vérité
imaginons Mark Zuckerberg
un homme qui possède on va faire la
chaîne je crois 68% des droits de vote
dans son entreprise il est pas
majoritaire en action mais majoritaire
en droit de vote
alors c'est pas lui qui prend toutes les
décisions il délègue mais enfin bon il a
un pouvoir il a 2 milliards 800 millions
de personnes pas loin de la moitié de
l'humanité en tout cas l'humanité adulte
qu'un compte c'est pas dire qu'on ne
s'informe que là mais quand même ça lui
donne un sacré pouvoir c'est plus de
pouvoir que Robert Hersant quand il
possédait je me rends compte que je fais
beaucoup de références un peu anciennes
là ce soir mais que mais c'est pour
essayer de parler de l'Ancien Monde et
du Nouveau Monde
un pouvoir complètement
aujourd'hui il a le droit des sa
plateforme elle a le droit des
êtres humains des individus elle
bénéficie d'une forme de liberté
d'expression c'est notamment lié à la
jurisprudence de la Cour suprême
américaine et elle a le pouvoir des
gouvernements et des parlements
et par exemple pendant l'épidémie de
soccerberg enfin quand je métaphorise
son entreprise a pris la décision à un
moment que le virus n'était pas sorti
des laboratoires de one
il y a pas que lui hein il y a beaucoup
de tacaste qui a dit la même chose de
beaucoup de ta caste qui a dit la même
chose qui a envoyé direct oui mais là
lui il a
il peut mettre ça dans un algorithme
dont on perçoit pas les effets parce que
c'est invisible
en plus
qui vont avoir le même point de vue et
là c'est le code c'est la loi mais en
plus c'est moins invisible c'est même
pas normalement nul les enseignants et
la loi les transparentes tout le monde
mais là c'est lois là elles sont
invisibles
parce que soi-disant c'est du secret
genre la recette au Coca-Cola
et donc il a décidé ça ne sort pas des
laboratoires de one comme ça
et puis à un moment il a changé d'avis
parce que Biden avait classifié un
rapport des services enseignement
américain qui a dit c'est une hypothèse
qui ne peut pas être exclue
donc là il y a ministère moi honnêtement
je ne sais pas d'où est sorti le virus
j'ai lu des enquêtes
j'ai des doutes je sais pas
j'aimerais bien lire plus d'enquête
d'ailleurs et très honnêtement à
l'époque j'aurais aimé lire beaucoup
plus enquête journalistiques et je
trouve qu'il y en a pas eu beaucoup
except et des choses qui n'ont pas été
remises en cause alors qu'elles auraient
dû l'être on était devant la plus grande
épidémie
depuis quand même des lustres et cette
enquête là elle était pas facile à faire
parce que c'est pas facile
nous on a été très performance sur le
covid on est sorti grâce à notre
communauté en Chine on a instauré un
protocole sanitaire chez nous très
rapidement on était au courant que ça
arrivait chez nous quand on a commencé à
en parler donc pas que ça sortait X ou Y
mais qui avait une grosse épidémie qui
arrivait en France
on a vu qu'il y avait les réseaux qui
invisibilité invisibilisé certains
postes qui
ne permettait pas en fait de prévenir
correctement la population mais si on a
vu beaucoup de journalistes dire oulala
les Cassandre vous vous êtes en train de
mettre le noir partout vous êtes des
corbeaux les autorités françaises sont
rassurantes en gros il s'était mis sous
le robinet de l'information du
gouvernement français
néanmoins
franchement aujourd'hui à qui tu fais
plus confiance que aux médias
d'information
on peut voir tout leur défauts ils sont
pas nuls il y a quand même d'abord de
l'exigence de du travail
voilà donc le côté on sera mieux quand
on en sera débarrassé franchement quand
on sera débarrassé on sera plus une
démocratie
donc ceux qui veulent détruire c'est
facile de détruire que détruire
difficile de construire mais construire
c'est plus dur parce que construire il
faut aussi s'intéresser d'un peu plus
près il fait pas de gueuler comme un
putois et
donc c'est comment on reconstruit ça et
qu'elle avantage dans un marché on donne
à ceux qui s'astreignent à plus
d'obligations qu'on vérifie plus qu'en
quête plus qui qui
ça se traîne à des règles éthiques qui
sont incorruptibles et et alors même
qu'aujourd'hui le problème de la matrice
c'est d'abord qu'il y a plus l'espace
commun disparaît on ne sait pas si celui
d'à côté
reçoit on est tous dans nos bulles dans
nos silos dans nos et cette énorme moins
en moins un espace commun
ça polarise
et la matrice c'est
je sais plus où je voulais finir cette
phrase là mais en tout cas
l'objectif c'est de reconstruire cette
fonction sociale du journaliste
et ça suppose de faire de la régulation
parce que la démocratie c'est des règles
le journaliste monsieur des règles et à
moins d'avoir une position anarchiste
mais moi je suis pas anarchiste dans le
bon sens du terme la monarchiste
anarchiste c'est-à-dire qui croit que le
qu'on peut vivre dans un monde où il y a
pas
ou le pouvoir serait
inexistant il y a toujours du pouvoir
mais ce qu'on veut du pouvoir qui
maîtriser démocratiquement où est-ce
qu'on préfère que dans la jungle le plus
fort l'emporte
et aujourd'hui ce cas ou informationnel
c'est une forme de jungle et c'est les
prédateurs qui l'emportent
et j'ai retrouvé là où je voulais en
venir dans cette matrice d'aujourd'hui
il y a une chose qui est différente
c'est que le système d'avant
les démocraties il y a chameau qui a
fait un bouquin qui s'appelle le peuple
contre la démocratie en tout cas très
intéressant et qui dit les démocraties
leur développement à leur poser sur
trois choses 1 une culture commune j'ai
pas dit unique
mais une culture
qui rassemble de un espace public qui
maintient aux marges
les hurluberlues les plus haineux les
fous furieux et trois une augmentation
progressive du niveau
bon moi je m'intéresse au niveau 2 ce
qui est nouveau 4e
vas-y la consommation énergétique
absolument oui mais qui va peut-être
avec le point 3 mais oui
qu'est-ce qui se passe quand la
consommation énergétique baisse
les systèmes et la c'est le système
économique si on raisonne encore de
système et perturber
et ça peut
entraîner là on voit bien que l'espèce
de mur énergétique devant lequel on se
trouve
peut rendre impossible le fonctionnement
du système tel qui l'être aujourd'hui
donc tes arguments en fait ils sont
caduc
les fondamentaux de soutenabilité de
notre société tu les as évaluées tu t'es
renseigné tu sais combien le monde
consomme de millions de barils par jour
tu t'es renseigné
journaliste ça fait pas de toi un
omniscient et chacun des sujets donc tu
sais que le pétrole va mal tu sais que
on parle toujours de l'énergie en Russie
mais il faudrait savoir aussi comment
vont aussi leur but de pétrole s'ils ont
été massacrés pas massacrés ce qu'ils
peuvent encore en tirer correctement à
quel prix
donc tu sais qu'on va sur une
décroissance de consommation énergétique
donc tu sais que notre démocratie n'est
pas sur les bonnes rails
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui va se passer
ce que vous avez anticipé vous votre
profession est-ce que vous avez anticipé
ces fondamentaux de soutenabilité qui
sont aussi les fondamentaux de
soutenabilité de votre profession
mais genre alors les fondamentaux de la
qualité de la profession oui on a lancé
bon toute initiative je peux raconter
j'ai pas développé sauf si ça
t'intéresse au synthèse ta communauté
qui est qui est comment on peut
rassembler les démocraties
pour éviter que ce soit Mark Zuckerberg
ou si Jean Ping ou un autre qui est
dicte les règles et que ce soit à
nouveau qu'on crée une forme d'espace
numérique démocratique avec à la fois
des règles démocratiques dans à
l'intérieur de l'espace et des systèmes
de protection vis-à-vis des offensives
de pays des politiques
et on a réussi à rassembler 45 états
conscient partenariat sur la formation
démocratie et à l'intérieur l'un des
sujets sur lesquels on a travaillé c'est
celui dont tu parles la soutenabilité du
journalisme et on a réclamé un New Deal
pour le journaliste
un New Deal notamment en termes de
financement du journaliste
corréler avec les obligations du journal
les obligations en termes de méthodes et
de règles éthique et en considérant que
par exemple
il serait normal et bien que dans les
démocraties 0,1% du PIB soit consacrés
soit des manations publiques ou privées
soient consacré à l'information que 1%
de l'aide au développement
de varier de consacrée aux soutien des
médias parce que dans les pays du Sud
s'il y a pas de média de journalistes
qui font leur boulot évidemment ça
baisse la confiance dans le système
hospitalier ça accro à la corruption etc
et
et donc c'est aussi un sujet sur lequel
oui on a travaillé mais je reviens au
sujet d'avant et même si on jongle
sur
la question que tu as posé en jongle
trop donc fini par me perdre dans le
jonglage sur ah oui j'en étais au fait
que notre espace public maintenant le
fonctionnement algorithmique
il met au cœur de l'espace public
des gens puissamment haineux
des uruberlus
des gens qui voient des complots partout
alors des complots il y en a je suis pas
en train de dire qu'il y a pas de
complot il y a même des gens qui
évoquent des complots qui existent qui
se font traiter de complotistes et même
moi ça m'est arrivé
moi par des présentateurs de télé quand
j'ai publié un bouquin qui s'appelait
Circus politique qui était un bouquin
sur Publier je crois en 2012 sur
l'organisation
comment à travers la gouvernance
mondiale et l'Union européenne
il y avait une formation oligarchique du
pouvoir
qui est un livre pas sur une position
anti-européenne mais qui c'est que là il
y avait un sujet de captation de capture
du législateur par puissance financière
à travers le fonctionnement
et je racontais on racontait avec mon
coteur Christophe Dubois
on est allé fou des archives aux
États-Unis au Pays-Bas partout et on
parlait par exemple de ces clubs que
sont le club medorbert gatrilatéral
dont on ne disait jamais qu'il y avait
qui faut monter des complots
mais on le racontait l'influence
idéologique qui pouvait avoir
donc c'était un récit d'influence
politique pas de complot et moi je me
souviens que sur des grandes chaînes de
télévision j'étais accueilli comme c'est
pas un peu complotiste votre truc donc
il faut se méfier de
l'abus d'accusation de complotisme
mais il y a aussi beaucoup de
complotistes et de gens qui voient des
complots partout même si là où c'est
simple parce que parfois la réalité est
très simple et
oui
et donc
et donc et eux
et on a des connaissances communes sur
le sujet enfin des connaissances des
gens qui peuvent
nous attaquer l'un et l'autre
qui finissent par écrire que tu
travailles pour la CIA que tu faisais
tel site moi ça m'est arrivé
et ça sans preuve et ça aujourd'hui
écris ça son preuve tu te retrouves
finalement au cœur de l'espace public et
avec une espèce d'avantage compétitif
parce que franchement c'est plus
attrayant qu'un papier qui a fait
l'objet d'une enquête etc donc là de nos
enjeux quand même c'est de sauvegarder
absolument la liberté d'expression mais
il n'y a pas de contradiction aussi de
faire en sorte qu'au cœur de la
discussion il y a quand même d'abord des
gens qui vérifient ce qu'ils disent
et ça il y a des moyens mais simplement
c'est moyen là c'est pas les mêmes
moyens qui a l'air pré-numérique il faut
les inventer il faut inventer du droit
il faut inventer de
des mêmes des nouvelles doctrines
juridiques et c'est tout le boulot qu'on
a fait avec cette initiative sur la
formation démocratique a été lancée en
2018 avec
commission avec des Nobels avec
des
anciens dirigeants pour se poser
dirigeants d'organisation internationale
des journalistes
notamment de pays dictateurs pour se
dire
qu'est-ce qu'on fait de cet espace
public comme on l'organise
et ça ça doit être débattu je vais me
faire avocat du diable mais quand je
t'entends
vous réclamez
il y a qu'un faucon pourquoi c'est pas
fait pourquoi il y a pas des gens qui se
retrouvent ces manches et qui ont décidé
de faire sans les états sans les casses
journalistique leur syndical et qui font
des gens opératifs et qui se disent on
va faire et ensuite les gens vont nous
copier
c'est ce qu'on a entreprises parce que
justement le côté on gueule de loin
c'est pas bien faut faire ça faut qu'on
Yaka
comme ça qu'on fait avancer les choses
donc un jour on s'est dit nous on va
essayer de lancer le truc et puis on va
voir comment c'est repris et donc c'est
là qu'on a réuni une commission et on
s'est posé les plus grandes questions
sur maintenant l'espace la matrice elle
est globale
c'est quoi ça doit être quoi ces grands
principes on a fait une déclaration sur
la formation démocratie et puis on
allait voir des chefs d'État de
gouvernement et alors il s'est passé un
truc donc je pensais pas une seconde ça
avait une chance de réussir mais à
l'aveugle c'est-à-dire avant même
d'avoir lu le texte un certain moment
dit on soutient l'initiative parce qu'on
apprécie la manière dont vous le faites
parce qu'on apprécie parce qu'on trouve
la logique pas mal et donc après on a
réussi à obtenir un partenariat qui est
maintenant signé par 45 États
démocratiques il y a la Corée du Sud il
y a l'Afrique du Sud le Canada le Costa
Rica l'Allemagne la France 24 pays de
l'Union européenne sur les 45
c'est les principes généraux alors on
peut dire ouais ça c'est juste des
principes généraux c'est flan mais il
faut commencer par des principes
généraux
et j'ai le sentiment de retourner en
classe parfois et
quand il rentre
et
on a ensuite on s'est dit voilà on a des
principes généraux il faut trouver là il
faut maintenant être beaucoup plus
précis et donc on a créé des groupes de
travail on a créé un groupe de travail
traité de la transparence des
algorithmes de la modération
de la méta régulation de la modération
c'est à dire qu'est-ce que la régulation
démocratique doit imposer à aux
plateformes numériques quand elles
distingue ce qui est licite ce qui est
palicite sur les messageries privées
parce qu'aujourd'hui les messageries
privées c'est l'équivalent de l'espace
public d'autrefois quand on peut envoyer
un mail à 4 millions de personnes c'est
pas comme quand on humectait une
enveloppe et qu'on y mettait une lettre
à l'intérieur et donc c'est aujourd'hui
dans des facteurs dans des démocraties
en Inde au Mexique ça peut être des
facteurs de perturbation démocratique
donc quelles règles il faut pour ça etc
et là on a fait des gros rapports mais
moi j'avais dit collaborateur
on fait de la proposition on dit voilà
ce qu'il faut mettre dans la loi et on a
fait comme ça 350 recommandations
ceux qui veulent lire ça s'appelle
rapport s'appelle pour en finir avec les
infos demies
et l'autre un journaliste et ensuite on
va les porter et là l'enjeu c'est
comment on arrive à l'imposer alors il y
a des législations européennes en cours
des sadma digital service Isaac
où il y a quelques avancées mais où ça
résout pas tout et par exemple
il y a pas vraiment de mécanisme de
promotion de la fiabilité de
l'information il n'y a pas d'obligation
de neutralité politique idéologique et
religieuse des plateformes numériques
autant les acteurs les individus les
journalistes on va tous ceux qui parlent
enfin
les entreprises les partis politiques
n'ont pas vocation à être la neutralité
ça n'existe pas par exemple y compris
pour le journaliste
non parce que la neutralité ça n'existe
pas on a toujours ce qu'il faut ce qu'il
faut c'est il y a la phrase de boeuf
Mary le fondateur du monde subjectivité
des intéressés mais la prétention à la
neutralité en revanche ce qui peut être
neutre c'est un espace
la place du village elle peut être ne
peut ne pas favoriser les endroits tous
les gens de gauche dans les dictatures
il n'y a pas de neutralité l'espace
public chinois
dans la ligne du parti l'espace public
iranien faut être dans la ligne du Guide
suprême dans une démocratie l'espace
français faut être un peu dans la ligne
du parti aussi non non il y a des dans
l'espace il y a des gens qui peuvent
avoir plus d'influence mais tu peux être
de droite ou gauche tu peux parler on
peut pas envoyer en tôle est-ce que je
peux dire un commentaire
de quelqu'un sur le chat là tu vas lui
répondre vous rendez vous compte que
votre concept de matrice ressemble
beaucoup à un concept réactionnaire de
la part d'un membre d'un groupe
d'influence entre parenthèses
journalistes
face à des concurrents entre guillemets
qui amenuisent cette influence on sent
une angoisse de perte ce pouvoir
hégémonique c'est amusant de voir que
l'ensemble des critiques portées portées
à cette matrice sont applicables et
pertinentes pour décrire le champ
journalistique la paille la poutre
moi j'aimerais bien engager une
conversation et malheureusement c'est
peut-être pas possible avec cette
personne
je connais pas son prénom je crois pas
j'aimerais lui demander ce qu'il veut
lui
parce que parce qu'on peut effectivement
critiquer journaliste mais là d'abord je
pense que je parle pas quand je
journaliste sinon je dirais pas tout ce
que j'ai dit je suis pas en citoyen
ce que tu viens de dire
c'est lourd non mais ce que je veux dire
c'est je parle en citoyen on peut avoir
je peux être en train de faire du vélo
et en même temps sur le balcon en train
de me regarder faire du vélo est-ce
qu'un journaliste doit pas parler comme
un médecin pourquoi un médecin il doit
il y a toujours sa conscience de
médecins quand il parle est-ce que le
journaliste doit toujours avoir sa
conscience avec la charte de Munich
gravée dans ces deux hémisphères il
devrait il devrait je suis un grand
partisan j'adore la charte de unique
avec ses 10 devoirs et 5 droits
et il y a d'ailleurs un problème
d'appliquer de des règles critiques
aujourd'hui
as-tu posé une question à laquelle j'ai
pas répondu mais je vis pas la question
de Jonas mais qui était ce qu'il fallait
ce qu'il fallait le comité d'éthique et
non j'essaie de voir j'ai dit que je
saurais pas ce que le journaliste parce
que
Jona et peut-être qu'il pourra attendre
tout à l'heure
il pense que c'est viable
une matrice est-ce qu'il a envie que ce
soit un milliardaire californien
californiens ou un potenta chinois qui
décide
de nos règles pour échanger pour notre
délibération publique et pour nos
conversations privées est-ce qu'il a
envie est-ce que ça lui va
Jona est-ce que ça lui va d'avoir
simplement
des gens qui s'expriment et dont il sait
pas qui parlent
et où il a aucun moyen de savoir
si c'est un peu fiable ou pas fiable
sinon c'est propre suppositions et ses
propres préjugés
et ce qu'il pense que ça va vraiment lui
servir en tant que citoyen ou même que
ça va l'aider à être à être plus libre
je crois pas
et
voilà je crois pas
oui mais tu connais celle qui dit on
commence à se sentir libre quand on fait
bouger ses chaînes
est-ce que tu penses que les
journalistes français ont des grosses
chaînes au pied
mais ils en ont évidemment
la chaîne c'est l'effet de système dont
je parlais c'est les chaînes c'est
l'organisation du marché qu'un site à
faire telle ou telle chose tu sais moi
j'ai une école de joie je voyais des
journalistes qui disait qu'il arrivait
par exemple les étudiants qui étaient
candidats c'est quoi l'actualité du jour
il se rendait pas compte que l'actualité
du jour c'est pas quelque chose qui
existe en soi c'est c'est des
présupposés qui fait qu'on qui font
qu'on n'attache plus d'importance à
telle ou tel événement
et
donc on a les chaînes c'est
ça peut être la demande du public parce
que l'effet de marché fait que on va
servir la demande
c'est le cas échéant
les moyens financiers dont on dispose et
qui font qu'on aura plus de moyens pour
aller là où là
ça peut être parfois le propriétaire qui
en décembre de la casse voilà et donc
mais je pense que les gens ils sont pas
tous des petits soldats d'information et
que quand même ce qu'on lit
fondamentalement
et vérifier
voilà alors est-ce que tu pourras me
demander le pourcentage à quel
pourcentage c'est vrai j'en sais rien si
tu veux demander ça veut dire quoi une
commande
ça veut pouvoir dire plusieurs choses si
c'est une commande pour moi c'est tiens
tu vas pas me faire un papier sur tel
sujet
on tient tu voudrais pas me faire un
papier pour dézinguer
moi il m'est arrivé de voir ça
je raconte dans mon bouquin parce que je
pense que j'ai fait la matrice je montre
tu me demandes de le montrer voilà
moi j'ai vu des journalistes dire
celui-là je me le payer maman j'avais
envie de faire un bouquin qui se
rappelait celui-là je veux le payer pour
en détour dans le truc
voilà le journaliste ils sont comme tout
le monde il y a plein qui ont des gros
défauts
mais
voilà je n'a tu te renseigneras comment
quand il y aura plus de journalistes un
commentaire un commentaire de quelqu'un
sur le chat
accepter que la neutralité n'existe pas
c'est s'autoriser à ne pas être neutre
c'est bien pratique
non au contraire enfin c'est là qu'il y
a des critiques
en fait il y a ceux qui moi je suis
objectif
et
on peut pas être neutre quand on regarde
l'immensité du réel parce qu'en fait
il y a deux choses différentes et qui
souvent sont
sources de grands conflits politiques
la vérité la réalité
et
on a besoin de vérité factuelle
fameuse phrase d'Anna rent la liberté
d'opinion est une farce si l'information
sur les faits n'est pas garantie et ce
ne sont pas les faits qui font l'objet
du dé du débat donc on a besoin de
vérités avec un grand V mais de choses
de fait établie
mais en présentant certains faits
établis
celui-là plutôt que celui-là plutôt que
celui-là plutôt que celui-là j'oriente
donc c'est en cela qu'il y a pas de
neutralité c'est pas possible
je mets mon regard quelque part
que je sois un individu non journaliste
ou un journaliste je décide de regarder
là plutôt que l'AS c'est pas neutre et
ça il faut en avoir conscience au
contraire c'est par tu parlais de quand
on commence à faire bouger chez chaîne
moi je pense que
c'est très spinosiste la liberté c'est
la d'abord la compréhension des des
mécanismes qui nous gouvernent
des déterministes et et
faut arriver à comprendre que tout
regard est un choix
et que
si on nid de gauche enfin je caricature
mais on s'intéressera plus à l'argent
des milliardaires si on est droite on
s'intéressera plus à l'argent des
syndicats
et que dans les deux cas qui sont dit
quelque chose devrait mais qui n'est
qu'une vue parcellaire et ça faut avoir
la modestie de voir que c'est
parcellaire
et ça vaut pour les journées ça vaut
pour chacun parce que chacun dans sa
position dans la société tout ça n'a
qu'une vue parcellaire
et ce qui est intéressant important
c'est une multiplier ces points de vue
et donc il suffit pas d'être dire des
choses vraies il faut essayer de dire
des choses vraies de différents points
de vue et donc avec différentes choses
frais et c'est pour ça qu'on a besoin
d'un cadre plus réaliste
et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs nous on ces
derniers temps on s'est beaucoup
intéressé à Bolloré
parce que vous l'aurez pour nous il est
il est en train d'instaurer un nouveau
système en France parce qu'il y avait
une règle jusqu'à présent à la
télévision qui est doctrine française
depuis longtemps c'est en pressé Krite
il y a beaucoup de médias donc il faut
un pluralisme externe c'est à dire une
diversité de l'inéditoriale et c'est le
principe de la régulation tandis que
pour la télévision il y avait une plus
grande rareté des ondes donc il fallait
du charisme interne c'est-à-dire sur
chaque chaîne on voit des gens
différents
ce qui est aussi un peu le cas dans la
presse écrite ou quand même qu'on lise
Le Figaro libération il y a des gens de
droite et de Gauchy parlent il y a pas
fait j'ai dit droit de gauche je reste
pas sur un truc droit de gauche c'est
métaphorique ça veut pas dire je crois
absolument assez notions là mais
là
quand et ça c'était donc tout à l'heure
je parlais de la fermesse doctrine aux
États-Unis qui avait sauté sur vegan et
qui avait entraîné la création de médias
ultra polarisés c'est-à-dire tout va
toujours dans le même sens
bah ça c'est dangereux parce que on peut
se dire oui mais chacun va avoir non ça
crée vraiment des polonisations et à la
fin on se retrouve comme aux États-Unis
avec des gens qui veulent plus vivre
dans le même pays qui peuvent plus
parler qui peuvent juste envie de se
mettre sur la figure
on n'y est pas encore totalement mais on
y arrivera peut-être et c'est pour ça
que Bolloré cnews qui est sur le modèle
de Fox News le Bolloré
il a quand même une spécificité par
rapport aux autres c'est qu'il essaie de
pousser un modèle
très éditorialisé où tout le monde va
dans le même sens et
ça c'est extrêmement dangereux et c'est
pour ça que nous on pense que là dessus
il faut que les institutions
démocratiques en l'occurrence là-dessus
l'arcom qui est l'ancien CSA ancien
Conseil Supérieur face respecter les
obligations qui sont dans les
dans les conventions qui sont les
contrats entre
l'arcom et ses chaînes où il y a
honnêteté de l'un de l'information
indépendance de l'information et
pluralisme
et on a besoin de faire respecter ça et
aujourd'hui de ce point de vue là cette
institution démocratique est trop faible
plutôt que décide lui imposer quoi que
ce soit pourquoi pas créer quelque chose
ailleurs
contrebalancera ça
quelque chose de plus intéressant
de plus je vais dire dans l'air du temps
créer sa propre tendance c'est à dire au
lieu regarde ce qu'on a fait nous ça va
faire dix ans qu'on est sur Youtube
décennies au départ tout le monde se
foutait de notre gueule parce que
c'était long c'était Harry ride mon
résultat des courses maintenant tout le
monde nous copie pourquoi parce que on a
créé notre trace on a fait notre trace
comme un skieur qui va skier dans la
poudreuse
on a ouvert un chemin le temps long
respecter son auditoire
respecter son les gens qui viennent de
toute nature ne pas les traiter de fou
Dingo et si les entendre communiquer
avec eux échanger
est-ce que le fait de vouloir imposer à
Bolloré une hyper régulation parce que
tu as peur
j'ai peur de quoi tu as peur qui
t'écrase parce que tu penses que ta
créativité n'est pas assez forte pour
contrebalancer ça je te lis un
commentaire je te lis un commentaire
dans la communauté son avis sur la
pensée unique est-ce une façon
d'infantiliser le peuple sous prétexte
de le prémunir de propagande point
d'interrogation l'âge d'or du panurgisme
j'ai pas compris gros est-ce que tu es
infantilise pas tout le monde en disant
voilà je vais te prémunir dans la
propagande je vais te prémunir des
opinions radicalisés parce que je vais
leur imposer une région mais moi
chacun pourra penser que je défends je
prêche pour ma paroisse les citoyens
citoyen sauf que il y a des journalistes
qui dévoient
cette fonction et c'est pas des journées
pas très intéressant est-ce que un
journaliste qui travaille pour un média
propagande est un journaliste si j'ai
une carte de presse en tout cas ce n'est
pas un journaliste digne de ce nom au
sens de la
Charte française qui commence par ça et
moi si on revient à avant ce qui s'est
passé avant pendant la guerre de 14
si on a
des médias des médias là je parle pas au
sens de médias d'information des sources
de communication qui balancent juste de
la haine ou comme Radio Mille collino
Rwanda
ou ses références le Mali et
[Musique]
du Rwanda Radio Mille Collines avant le
génocide parce que le Mali a fait ou
je parle même pas des médias de
propagande dans les régimes autoritaires
je parle
de médias qui peuvent être dans des
systèmes de liberté et qui ballon c'est
continu de la propagande de la haine etc
fils de l'histoire ça se termine mal
donc l'idée voilà la jungle ça se
termine mal et moi je trouve ça étonnant
qu'on a envie de revivre dans la jungle
tu te rappelles le conflit avec il faut
pas ce que moi le risque que certains
peuvent voir et légitimement d'accord il
dit ça mais en fait c'est une manière de
réacaparer pour son groupe social le
contrôle ça peut être ça
et ce risque qu'il existe
par exemple il y a un danger en ce
moment qui est le cercle de la raison
d'un côté et les obscurantistes de
l'autre
et ça c'est dangereux l'idée
certains et je vois non parfois dans le
milieu disent mais peut-être qu'il
faudrait d'ailleurs quand il y a un
consensus scientifique sur quelque chose
il peut y avoir des tentatives de dire
la vérité est là et ça moi je pense
qu'il faut rester à une vision
philosophie libérale philosophie
politique libérale qui est nul ne
connaît la vérité nul ne la détient plus
exactement la question c'est qu'on
puisse la rechercher et qu'on puisse et
qui est que ceux qui la recherche que ça
soit favorisé cette recherche et
et sinon on s'en sortir enfin je crois
vraiment que ceux qui
pensent ça de bonne foi se trompent mais
l'enjeu effectivement j'y reviens c'est
de d'éviter le côté polarisation des
deux côtés parce qu'on est dans un
moment où en gros c'est comme histoire
du train qui part dans une gare
on voit les autres en train de se
polariser on se voit moins soit en train
de polariser et le vrai risque je
parlais tout à l'heure et je vais venir
à l'exemple américain vérité
moi il y a quand même question qui me
trou beaucoup c'est pourquoi il y a la
moitié des Américains grosso modo qui
croit qu'il y a plus de vérité dans les
mensonges de Trump
que dans les vérités factuelles des
journaux de la côte ouest c'est sûr
c'est quoi là non mais en gros gros
ça dépend fonctionnement
ça veut dire en fonction des sondages et
des périodes on a près de la moitié du
sondages comment foncer sondage
que tu connais que chaque année
de sondage il y a pas très longtemps là
pourquoi il y a des gens qui sont prêts
à croire alors même que
de mon point de vue incontestablement il
y a des méthodes de vérification plus
solides
c'est au nom de votre vérité n'est pas
notre réalité
et votre vérité certes peut-être vous
dites des choses vraies qui sont
vérifiées mais les faits que vous allez
choisir
ne
sont pas ce qu'on voit nous ce qu'on
peut là je parle même pas de perception
je parle pas de son pas les faits que
que nous nous constatons nous
et donc c'est là qu'il nous faut des
médias qui disent des choses vraies mais
le vrai n'est pas suffisant
il faut un vrai qu'il soit suffisamment
équilibré on aille regarder partout et
en disant des choses purement vrai on
peut défendre
c'est les intérêts de son groupe social
et donc cette idée là et qui n'est pas
du tout le mensonge et qui voit la
vérité je suis vraiment pas dans ce
relativisme là
mais ça fait quand même il faut se
parler et qu'il faut essayer de
comprendre pourquoi des gens ne
vérité factuelle ne leur inspire pas
confiance
qu'est-ce qu'il y a de revendications
démocratique dans le populisme
et l'enjeu qu'on a tous et je pense
qu'on a tous le même intérêt
qu'on soit populiste qu'on soit pas
populiste c'est qu'on a quand même
intérêt à vivre dans le même pays
à vivre ensemble et que pour ça il faut
retrouver le moyen de se parler à un
moment où on se parle plus et c'est pour
ça que c'est pour ça que ça veut dire
arrêter le journaliste quand ils
invitent les gens qui ne comprennent pas
en leur disant c'est des douze
hurluberlues c'est des cinglé c'est des
agités il faut pas leur parler où il
faut les mettre en boîte non mais si tu
as est-ce qu'il y a pas un peu trop de
pédance dans la dans la bouche des
journalistes en France il y a beaucoup
de mépris
il y a bout de la haine et
le mépris social c'est toujours
désastreux
et bien sûr qu'il peut y avoir des
positions de
surplombions sérieusement et et si vous
nous aimez pas si vous êtes des couilles
oui ça existe
encore plus de couillon qui les déteste
donc
et c'est l'histoire du de l'arrivée
lycée mimétique chacun monte aux
extraits de son côté comme ça et le
fossé c'est l'argile
le truc c'est qu'il y a beaucoup moins
de journalistes que personne est larve
et donc faut faire attention
oui mais
bon tout le public n'est pas énervé tous
les journalistes sont pas pareil mais
mais en tout cas il y a cette mécanique
là
et parce que la polarisation elle peut
maintenant être entre
elle est en train de s'étendre même
entre media d'ailleurs
alors il y a un moment le problème c'est
que les médias ils excluaient trop les
gens qui pensaient pas disons au centre
maintenant on peut avoir une tendance à
trop exclure ceux qui sont au centre et
parce que les c'est mieux d'être sur le
bord tu captes plus l'attention
et c'est juste comment on arrive mais je
pense qu'on a un enjeu commun quel droit
à la formation on veut et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que RSF on va bientôt lancer
un bus pour le droit à l'information non
non mais ça paraît bête mais alors vas-y
mais on va circuler dans la France
entière pour organiser des assemblées
citoyennes pour faire parler en mettant
en présence au même niveau
journaliste et public le public dans sa
diversité j'espère les journalistes dans
leur diversité aussi pour se mettre au
service d'un objectif commun qui est pas
la sauvegarde des intérêts catégoriels
des journalistes
qui est pas l'enfermement dans la
critique parfois facile et franchement
beaucoup s'enferment dans la critique
des médias sans voir que en fait une
manière de critiquer le messager mais
enfin est-ce que tu penses d'acrymède
des acrimède
je vais être très franc moi j'ai
beaucoup alors moi j'ai beaucoup
je vais être très honnête donc je pense
que c'est intéressant moi je j'ai dû à
chaque fois les nouveaux champs de garde
la limite tous ces bouquins quand
j'étais directeur du CFG je suis arrivé
sous le bras je lui ai raconté l'autre
jour parce que j'ai croisé l'autre jour
le bouquin de Ruffin les petits soldats
du journalisme
qu'à mon avis ressemblait plus aux
rédactions qu'aux écoles de journalistes
mais ça c'est je
mais à crimed
par ailleurs a quand même
une orientation idéologique forte et ne
le reconnaît pas toujours je trouve dans
sa manière de voir les choses et et il
arrive que
le préjugé idéologique l'emporte sur
l'enquête est-ce que tu m'autorises à
lire un commentaire de la communauté
n'existe-t-il pas une paresse
journalistique quant aux sollicitations
d'experts de plateau alors que nos pays
notre pays regorgent de chercheurs
indépendants
aux effets de système si on cherche à
faire de l'audience soit un bon client
et le bon client c'est quelqu'un qui est
capable d'articuler quelques phrases de
dire des choses katchi comment dire
forte clair
c'est pas toujours le plus pertinent
et donc c'est vrai que le système qui
est tel qu'il est organisé
peut exclure des gens comportant des
choses extrêmement intéressantes à dire
et le plateau par ailleurs
fini vite en blabla
moi je trouve qu'il y a quelque chose
d'effrayant sur les plateaux c'est quand
les journalistes et les politiques se
ressemblent et qui sont les
connaissaient pas avant on
les distinguerait pas
tu fais référence à qui là non mais
notamment au plateau parfois sur la
chaîne tout info ou honnêtement tout le
monde débat et les politiques c'est ce
comporte en journaliste et les
journalistes comportent en politique en
gros ça va pas les gens ils trouvent
tout ça après ils disent qui est qui et
franchement c'est très noble d'être
politique j'ai rien contre les
politiques je trouve que c'est très
noble d'être journaliste aussi mais
chacun son rôle dans la société et je
pense qu'il se style doit prohiber les
conflits d'intérêts elle doit elle doit
faire que chacun remplit bien sa
fonction et voilà politique est là pour
convaincre un jour il sera là s'il est
élu pour décider
plus tard on lui demandera des comptes
c'est ça la démocratie et puis on
délibère
mais le journaliste il est là pour
apporter le fruit de ses constatations
et de ses recherches ce que je peux te
dire un autre commentaire
ne pensez-vous pas que si les
infractions nous articles de la Charte
de Munich était assorti de peine de
prison suffisamment lourde pour être
dissuasive les chaînes comme BFM TV
n'auraient-ils pas n'aurait-il pas déjà
disparu
d'abord franchement je pense que la
solution de mettre les journalistes en
prison n'est jamais une très bonne
solution et il y a que les régimes
autoritaires évidemment qu'ils font
aujourd'hui on n'a pas non mais
aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'on a retire
aujourd'hui
la question et peut-être c'est une
manière un peu caricaturale de poser la
question je suppose mais il y a pas de
sanction pour les vrais sanctions pour
les infractions la déontologie
comment on fait
il y a un nouveau conseil de médiation
et journalistique qui a été créé alors
pour l'instant il y a surtout des
syndicats il y a pas les éditeurs de
presse c'est-à-dire
les organisations les organismes nous on
pense que l'enjeu aujourd'hui il faut
surtout pas regarder juste le secteur
des médias que ça c'est le passé parce
que sur Facebook
le secteur des médias il existe pas il y
a tous les acteurs dans le champ de
l'information et aujourd'hui le marché
de l'information le champ de
l'information il est tendu à tout et
donc alors il y a ceux qui disent mais
il faut réintroduire il y avait de
l'éthique journalistique il faut faire
une éthique de la conversation
comment on fait
nous ce qu'on pense et je raconte et ce
qu'on a construit parce qu'au-delà on
essaie de pas se contenter de penser
mais de d'agir c'est qu'il faut
retrouver des moyens de distinguer ceux
qui font qui vérifient qui probe les
conflits d'intérêts etc et de les
pousser en avant dans l'indexation logo
rythmique de faire en sorte qu'ils aient
plus accès à l'argent des annonceurs
plutôt que ça a financer de la
désinformation de la rumeur
que les subventions publiques il y a
ceux qui font la preuve de leur
indépendance etc et donc on a construit
tout un système qui s'appelle la en
anglais et journal zimm shot initiative
initiative pour la confiance dans la
formation
est fondée sur de l'auto-agulation un
cadre de référence à travers une norme
européenne le marché est incertification
etc on a monté tout un dispositif qui
est une solution de marché qui permet
d'éviter que ce soit
un pouvoir qui prennent la décision de
qui est journaliste qui l'est pas
que ce soit ni les plateformes ni les
États mais qui est un mécanisme de
marché
qui qui permettent de davantager ceux
qui respectent les grands principes du
journaliste
on élargit un peu le les choses c'est la
guerre
ça castagne il y a encore des gamins qui
se prennent des bombes sur la tête il y
a encore des femmes qui se prennent des
bombes sur la tête des personnes âgées
qui se prennent des bonbons sur la tête
des deux côtés
oui ou non
je sais pas connaissance que les charges
ukrainien soient rentrés en Russie
est-ce que est-ce que tu as pris
connaissance que dans le don de base et
à côté comment ça s'appelle Lougansk ils
sont fait bombarder la gueule j'ai
l'impression que le dire c'est sale
enfin on se fait dire des deux côtés
parce que tout sont en Ukraine
dans le don de base il y a eu
des procrainiens enfin des Ukrainiens
pro Ukrainiens des Ukrainiens prorus et
des troupes russes déguisés
en ukrainien prorus
tu sais pourquoi je te pose cette
question selon le nu en ce moment il y a
un reporter de guerre une reporter de
guerre
qui fait le buzz il y a une autre
communauté qui nous a demandé de
s'intéresser à ce qui se passait on a
regardé on a écouté ses déclarations on
connaît des reporters de guerre depuis
longtemps
et on a senti qu'elle était quand même
énervée
est-ce que tu en as entendu parler
qu'est-ce que tu en penses je pense
qu'il suffit pas d'être énervé pour
avoir raison
et qu'aujourd'hui
quiconque se met dans la position de la
victime je suis victime de cet
abominable système des médias qui ne
veut pas dire la vérité
je suis authentiquement énervé on a une
présomption de fiabilité parce qu'on
pense tellement que le système est
pourri qu'on finit par croire après
n'importe qui
et ça je pense que
le site
les médias plus institutionnels même si
l'expression du dette mais plus
installée plus on passe à mentors
cette jeune femme
elle prétend qu'il y a eu un génocide
elle a pas de preuve elle donne des
chiffres
en fait en s'inspirant de ceux de l'ONU
elle parle de 13000 morts
elle laisse sa pensée que tous les morts
sont du même côté
or quand on regarde les chiffres de
l'ONU c'est pas ça c'est de côté donc
elle fait dans ses interprétations si je
me trompe pas trafica pour les chiffres
et puis elle a été amenée d'un seul côté
accompagnant
notamment des gens qui servent certains
types de discours donc moi je suis pas
là pour dire qu'il y a raison ou pas
parce que je suis jamais allé dans le
monde basse j'ai pas enquêté à titre
personnel de ce que j'ai lu
je n'ai pas l'impression qu'il y a
raison de lui accorder une confiance
plus grande qu'aux médias qui
ont raconté ce qui se passait dans cette
région
et et
c'est pas faux et parfois peut-être
c'est pas assez souligné que dans sa
façon de pays d'Europe de l'Est il y a
des minorités russophone
qui sont pas toujours bien traités
je sais pas l'autre jour j'étais en
Estonie que une vraie démocratie
je crois qu'il y a un tiers de la
population qui russophone je crois que
le maire enfin je peux je me trompe pas
je voudrais pas dire une heure je crois
que le maire de Tallin est russophone
mais qui a aucun ministre
donc il y a sans doute les sujets
tout est pas purement noir et blanc
mais aucun moment ça justifie d'aller
balancer des bombes sur ma rue Paul sur
des théâtres est attaqué comme ça et
donc et là
on lit partout j'ai des
amis y compris dans ta communauté
qui parle du régime nazi
un peu conformément au discours de
Poutine du régime nazi de Zelinski
franchement j'ai lu oui il y a des nazis
en
Ukraine
en Allemagne
il y en a en France
voilà il y a les batailles
donc il y a là un mensonge quand même
porté par le régime de Poutine
portée de manière
vraiment scandaleuse en
activant le traumatisme russe parce que
il y a un traumatisme lié aux douleurs
de l'histoire en Russie qui est assez
peu imaginable y compris dans un pays
qui n'a aussi subi
quelques tragédies au 20e siècle mais
pas à la mesure de ce qui s'est passé et
il active à travers l'accusation
néonazisme à travers l'appareil de
propagande et de censure
il réactive ça
la garde de l'information a favoriser
qui est d'abord une guerre de
l'information contre les Russes contre
le peuple russe entre les citoyens
russes
parfois très enfin très j'allais dire je
trouve plus le terme enfin qui l'accepte
volontiers pour ça pour un grand nombre
d'entre eux
amener à cette guerre et qui
ensuite je pense que c'est le rôle des
journalistes de parler des bases de
l'OTAN de y compris des centres de
recherche biologique on peut avoir des
enquêtes sur ces sujets là moi j'ai
découvert qu'il y avait des centres de
recherche biologiques dont je ne sais
pas c'est investisseurs vocation
militaire ou pas mais
j'ai un peu regardé parce que quelqu'un
m'a alerté quelqu'un qui d'ailleurs m'a
dit m'a parlé du régime nazi en y
croyant moi franchement je suis
convaincu à 0%
et les centres de recherche biologiques
j'ai vu que la
l'assistance c'est-à-dire l'une des
adjointes de blinken le secrétaire
d'État américain avait parlé
du fait qu'il fallait démanteler des
centres de recherche biologique de peur
que ça saisit par les Russes je crois
ces sources là parce que tu étais sûr du
coup
une vidéo d'elle en parlant ouais mais
c'était
pas je n'ai pas le mais en tout cas il y
a la matière à enquête
mais moi je m'étonne quand même que des
gens qui prétendent défendre la
démocratie sont en adoration devant un
régime autoritaire
et si eux-mêmes se trouvait dans ce
régime il serait en tôle depuis belle
lurette ou éliminer d'une manière ou
d'une autre où on les aurait asséchés
et qui qu'on installe une espèce de
fausse symétrie entre un régime
disons-le d'oppression et des régimes
démocratiques qui peuvent avoir plein de
défauts mais quand même on peut dire ce
qu'on veut
il peut attaquer pour insultes c'est une
question alors formellement il y a trois
infractions de presse infraction de
liberté d'expression la diffamation
l'injure et l'insulte
l'Ukraine comment ça va en ce moment
c'est la merde les
Ukrainiens fuis par million
principalement des gamins avec des
femmes
comment ça va se régler cette histoire
là est-ce que tu as une idée est-ce que
la presse peut jouer
un rôle est-ce que est-ce qu'on est
parti pour une troisième guerre mondiale
quel est ton sentiment par rapport à ça
j'espère qu'on n'est pas parti pour une
troisième guerre mondiale et j'espère
que j'ai pas trop frais de promo sur mon
bouquin et je vais parler du premier
chapitre
je pensais pas qu'il se
d'actualité enfin qui
certains m'avait dit des lecteurs des
proches m'avait dit non mais là tu trop
déconnecté mon premier chapitre il est
sur l'horloge de l'Apocalypse je sais
pas si tu vois ce que c'est l'horloge de
la production
créant en 1947 donc c'est un instrument
de mesure bon qui vaut ce qu'il vaut
mais créé par des scientifiques
de l'université de Chicago par Einstein
open Heimer du programme américain qui
était dans les premiers pour essayer de
d'indiquer chaque année à quel point
il est ensuite il est passé aux
États-Unis
pour essayer de
dire à quelle distance on se trouve de
la destruction du risque de destruction
enfin de la destruction finale sur une
échelle de temps de 0 heure
à minuit
et cette horloge de l'Apocalypse dooms
déclock en anglais elle existe depuis là
quand elle est créée en 47 les
scientifiques nous sommes à 7 minutes
sur l'échelle alors le zéro c'est les
débuts de l'humanité
il nous reste que 7 minutes par rapport
à l'échelle de temps de l'humanité
puis ça varie au fil du temps en
fonction alors au moment des actrices
des fusées de Cuba je sais plus à
combien on retourne peut-être 4 minutes
ou un truc comme ça au moment de la
détente 72
ça passe à 12 minutes en 90 juste après
la chute du mur de Berlin ça passe à 17
minutes
on a plus de temps
depuis deux ans d'après les mêmes
scientifiques il y a toujours 13 membres
du enfin lauréat du Nobel alors comité
parce qu'il veut pas dire que tout est
vrai c'est quand même une échelle de
fait ça revient à prédire l'avenir donc
c'est pas
purement scientifique ils nous disent
une minute et 40 secondes et quand on
regarde l'argumentation pourquoi
notamment à cause des fake news des
fausses infos tu risques engendrés par
les fausses informations
par la propagande les rumeurs etc
et donc oui c'est garde de l'information
ces fausses informations
elles peuvent mener à des catastrophes
donc on a un intérêt à régler le sujet
vite à reprendre le contrôle de la
matrice vide
pour la démocratie mais aussi pour la
paix
pour la concorde civile au sein des
nations mais aussi pour la Concorde
à l'échelle internationale et
malheureusement c'est cette cette guerre
elle en est
presque une preuve et donc comment ça va
se finir moi j'en sais rien
quand je dirige le cfjim dans ma
première allocution aux élèves le
premier jour je disais ne faut jamais
prédire l'avenir même ce qui se passera
demain sans rien
en revanche donner nous tous les
éléments pour qu'on fait
on ne peut être que extrêmement inquiet
de la fermeture
de l'autoritarisme
russe et de l'extinction des dernières
poches de résistance du journaliste
indépendant par Poutine
il reste avec cette nouvelle loi qui
publie de 15 ans de prison qui compte
critique l'armée ou dit il y a une
guerre on parle d'une invasion c'est
vraiment 1984 il faut pas dire le mot
et ça n'est que la dernière arme dans un
arsenal juridique ou les lois sont
arrangées comme ça on peut les utiliser
de manière arbitraire
ou la législation sur les agents de
l'étranger là est utilisé de manière
aberrante arbitraire c'est-à-dire on
pouvait être qualifié d'agent de
l'étranger parce que on avait des
abonnés à l'étranger
et où il reste pas grand chose il reste
Noël à Gazzetta
donc ce journal martyre le journal
d'anapoli comme skyya
5 jours restitués au fil de des 20
dernières années
continue à travailler
il reste des gens sur place la rédaction
des coûts de Moscou qui appartenait en
partie à gaz Prom et qui a été dissoute
par le propriétaire à des gens essayer
de travailler sur les réseaux sociaux
mais en gros il y a eu on est dans un
moment je publie le jour un tribune dans
plein de journaux européens avec
Mireille cigare et l'ancien fondateur de
Dolce de cette télé indépendance on est
dans une vague d'immigration
deux journalistes d'artistes de
producteur et de réalisateur de films
qui est semblable à celle du 1918 face
au bulgit
pour la Russie c'est
une catastrophe pour la Russie ça peut
l'être pour le reste du monde en
fonction des scénarios
donc
raison de plus pour essayer de reprendre
le contrôle de la matrice pour essayer
d'éviter
la destruction ou la fragilisation des
démocraties par des médias de propagande
alors en faisant attention à ne pas
entrer dans des décisions arbitraires
politiques il faudrait pas en profiter
pour réduire la liberté d'expression
tout ça doit être sur un socle juridique
solide
les dernières décisions prises de
bannissement de RTS cosmique n'ont pas
été pris sur un socle enfin ils ont été
pris sur un socle le jeudi qui n'est pas
le socle de la régulation des médias
qui a un autre socle qui régime de
sanctions il y a besoin d'un système
juridique et RSF on a fait des
propositions je vais pas décliner ici
c'est un peu compliqué mais ceux dans la
communauté qui ont envie d'aller voir il
pouvait taper système de protection des
espaces à formationnels démocratiques
il faut là aussi inventer du droit on va
pas s'en sortir quand on rencontre un
juriste souvent il y a mais rien n'a
changé etc il y avait déjà de la
propagande avant il y avait déjà de
c'est vrai mais ce qui est fondamental
ou différent c'est que le législateur
n'est plus le même c'est les plateformes
c'est les réseaux sociaux d'ailleurs
elles ont pris des décisions
alors vis-à-vis de régime autoritaire en
ce moment elle peuvent trouver en quoi
elles peuvent être des facteurs de
liberté
mais elles ont aussi pris des décisions
qui sont quand même sur lesquels on peut
se poser des questions la décision de
facebook moi je trouve ça vertigineux
alors il y avait les décisions de
Facebook je parlais tout à l'heure sur
le covid il y a eu les décisions de
Facebook Twitter et des autres sur les
comptes de Trump alors certains en plus
dire bon bah c'est Trump c'est un moment
d'appel à l'insurrection faut pas
l'oublier mais quand même c'est
vertigineux
quels espoir entre leurs mains parce que
demain elles peuvent le faire pour toi
pour n'importe quel membre de la
communauté pour moi bien sûr je ne ou
pour telle responsable politique parce
que
il faut pas leur laisser ce pouvoir en
dehors d'un cas de contrôle démocratique
et il y a eu un truc nouveau là c'est
qu'elle elles ont dérogé à leurs propres
règles de modération dans plusieurs pays
de l'Europe orientale sur on peut
appeler à tuer l'envahisseur
alors qu'en tant de guerre des gens ont
envie de l'envahisseurs on peut
comprendre c'est l'acte de résistance
mais est-ce qu'on peut accepter que les
plateformes numériques prennent ce genre
de décision et demain
franchement c'est un pouvoir beaucoup
trop grand pour qu'on leur laisse
beaucoup plus longtemps
c'était terrifiant et et
ça veut pas dire que tout tous les
propriétaires des plateformes sont tous
mal intentionnés mais c'est quand même
une forme de casque qui n'a pas les
mêmes aspirations que nous
qui a envie de vivre sur des îles
désertes sur Mars
la sécession des élites mais alors là
c'est la sécession de la super super
classe
et donc leurs intérêts sont pas nos
intérêts collectifs
d'où la nécessité de ramener de la
démocratie dans tout ça comment tu
expliques du fait que on est au 21e
siècle
[Musique]
qui encore des journalistes qui se font
cartonnés avec des des balles qui se
font tirer comme des lapins sur le
terrain comment t'explique ça on est
encore une société je vais être vulgaire
on est des macaques comment ça se fait
que notre presse est pas protégée et que
notre presse n'est pas un sauf conduit
comment ça se fait encore
avant le monde d'avant je disais les
journalistes avaient une forme de
monopole il fallait transiter par eux si
on voulait faire passer un message
et qui était un peu filtré et
heureusement qu'il était vite fait parce
que c'est le rôle des journalistes d'une
certaine manière de filtrer qu'est-ce
qui est intéressant pas intéressant
selon eux
qu'est-ce qui est de la foutaise absolue
auquel cas il vaut mieux pas qu'est-ce
qui a une présomption de véracité etc et
donc même un belligérant dans une guerre
il est pas intérêt à tuer un journaliste
parce qu'il tuait quelqu'un par lequel à
qui il a laissé mais là aujourd'hui tous
les pouvoirs
et les individus des individus vont
pouvoir être limité aux entreprises
multinationales en passant par les
groupes religieux par les associations
les ONG les états enfin tout le monde
peut s'adresser directement à son public
ce qu'on appelle la désintermédiation
donc là des intermédiations on peut en
voir tous les avantages et elle a des
avantages et qu'avant la médiation elle
avait des défauts on les a un peu
évoqués
et donc ça permet d'éviter ses défauts
mais en revanche on a plein d'autres
et c'est notamment que
chacun peut manipuler à sa guise
et ça c'est
il faut qu'on trouve à l'air de la
désintermédiation quelles règles il faut
poser on reviendra pour le monde d'avant
et c'est pas souhaitable
il faut que tout ça soit un programme
démocratique et les plateformes elles
ont aussi un potentiel de programmer la
démocratique puisque la communication
plus horizontale parce que d'éviter
précisément le filtrage qui peut avoir
des infos sur lequel peuvent poser des
contraintes des influences
intéressées ou à la solde de certains
groupes encore une fois ça permet de
revenir sur des systèmes de domination
mais ça permet d'en installer d'autres
et là faut pas être le conduit village
qui applaudit à la destruction des
anciens
problèmes pour avoir des problèmes
encore plus grands
je reviens je reviens sur le fait que
les journalistes sont devenus des cibles
et donc oui et donc comme c'est pour ça
que maintenant ils sont si à mon visés
que ce soit par des groupes mafieux des
belligérants dans les guerres
la plupart des journalistes qui meurent
aujourd'hui enfin qui sont tués pardon
dans l'exercice c'est pas juste qui
meurt 121 de criska ils sont tués ils
sont tués délibérément pas victimes des
risques du métier parce que simplement
ils étaient aux mauvais endroit mauvais
moment
est-ce que c'est pas aussi du fait que
certains journalistes ont été
instrumentés par des services de
renseignement et maintenant journaliste
est égal pour certains
comme
comment dire
faisant partie d'autres choses que de la
presse
mais qui est quelque chose
[Musique]
c'est le prétexte qui est il travaille
pour l'intelligence du coin où il
travaille pour tel pays
il y a toujours un fond de vérité
là-dedans on a rencontré des faux
toujours certainement pas un fond de
vérité un tout petit peu on a rencontré
des photos journalistes qui
travaillaient dans certains grands
journaux français qui après avoir pris
leur retraite
nous ont fait des confidences sur le
fait qu'ils ont été recrutés pour aller
faire machin pour aller faire d'études
et que sous prétexte d'être drapé dans
le
l'étendard du journalisme en fait
c'était des
informateurs
les groupes terroristes utilisent
souvent ce prétexte là pour dire voilà
ça n'est pas des journalistes c'est vrai
c'est fou est-ce que les journalistes
ont un petit peu traîné dans la
barbouserie pour certains mais que
certains
qui ont eu des cas d'abord d'agents se
faisant passer pour des journalistes
merci d'avoir reformuler
parfois d'aujourd'hui
on peut dire que ça n'est jamais arrivé
ça lui arrive moi jamais
de journalistes qui parfois ont envie de
rendre des services moi j'ai une
histoire marrante à raconter c'est
ministre d'affaires étrangères qui me
l'avait raconté je tenais d'autres
il y a un journaliste parisien qui
appelait les ministres étrangères en
disant monsieur le ministre est-ce que
je vais à tel endroit est-ce que vous
avez une mission secrète pour moi
c'est un cas je raconte parce que c'est
le cas qu'on se raconte c'est pas la
règle générale
la plupart des l'immense majorité des
photos reporters des gens qui sont pas
ils travaillent pas pour l'esclavage
donc voilà il y a eu quelques exceptions
et de fait nous
si des services de renseignements
envoient des agents et il y a eu des cas
notamment dans l'est de l'Afrique dans
la corde de l'Afrique mais comme je me
suis je me souviens de pays mais je sais
plus je
désastreux parce que le jour où s'est
découvert ça jette la suspicion et ça
fragilise les journalistes
c'est dramatique ah mais c'est
dramatique
mais enfin la plupart
tu vois en Iran il y a plein de tôle qui
sont pour espionnage
l'instrumentalisation du droit ils ont
des vignes
torturé etc alors que juste
ils étaient ouverts aussi des libertés
donc l'accusation d'espionnage elle est
aussi
infamante et
instrumentalisé utilisé simplement quand
on n'a rien d'autre à dire c'est facile
on dit un espion et puis tu travailles
pour
tu travailles pour l'ennemi donc
est-ce qu'il faudrait pas je vais
caricatural mais au lieu de
les mettre avec des gilets par balles
bleu marqué presse
faudrait vraiment les rendre visible je
sais pas mais des gilets pare-balles
rose fuchsia
bonjour mais là les soldats russes ont
tirés sur plein d'équipes de télévision
avant qu'ils ont l'équipe de Sky News
oui franchement ils se sont faits mais
avoué non mais tu aurais pu mettre un
gilet laser ils ont retiré dessus
à ma connaissance oui je crois que je te
dis à l'intérieur de l'automne je me
trompe
si mes souvenirs enfin qui sont des
souvenirs en direction bon les
Américains avaient prévenu qu'ils
allaient bombarder
RSF à l'époque à la critiqué ce
bombardement et par sinistre le régime
de milieux et vite avait maintenu des
gens à l'intérieur pour faire des
victimes
j'ai une petite anecdote personnelle le
jour a été adopté la dernière résolution
du Conseil de sécurité des Nations Unies
sur la protection des journalistes
c'était en mai 2015
j'étais au Conseil de sécurité j'ai
intervenu devant le Conseil de sécurité
pour cette adoption
et là je me souviens du représentant
russe
alors qui a été adopté donc du
représentants en russe
les diplomates russes sont un énorme
talent
longtemps été le ambassadeur là-bas
c'était pas lui
c'était plus lui à ce moment-là
rappelons cet événement qui est souvent
utilisé par
et oui voilà donc c'était pas une
antenne mais c'est
mais de fait alors moi j'étais pas du
tout un rapporteur sans frontière à
l'époque mais je crois que représente
critiqué quel que soit la nature
propagandise de 7 et il y avait aussi
une instrumentalisation
donc nous on a déposé plainte devant la
Cour pénal internationale devant le
procureur
pour Kim de guerre non on a envoyé une
plainte complémentaire hier
et les journalistes il y a mon visé
à court terme va changer les choses mais
il y a des obligations qui sont faites
par le don international faut envoyer
des signaux clairs et notre objectif
c'est que dans l'ensemble du monde
aujourd'hui 90% des des assassinats ou
des homicides contre les journalistes
font pas l'objet de poursuite ou de
sanctions
il faut renverser ça
il faut réintimider ceux qui commettent
ces actes et pour ça faut quand même
faire progresser l'application durant
international tu parles du droit
international
les Russes en profitent bien en ce
moment ils disent les Américains l'Irak
ils ont ils sont ils ont pas fouillé le
droit international pourquoi nous on ne
le ferait pas
est-ce que il y a moyen de faire
respecter le droit international ou
c'est simplement cosmétique de dire la
communauté internationale le droit
international
quand ils font référence ou du moins
même certains journalistes français
disent en Irak
c'était la boucherie
uranium appauvri
au bombarde à tout va et en plus
derrière on met des sanctions c'est la
population lambda qui prend
les Russes ont utilisé ça pour dire le
droit international on peut rien faire
on bombarde bombarde regardez ce qu'ils
ont fait avant
l'autocritique journalistique sur ce qui
s'est passé il doit se trouver où sur le
journalistique il y a eu des
journalistes américains enfin je me
souviens
coule pas au nom des médias faute toi
il y a eu des journalistes qu'à l'époque
on portait les mensonges américains
beaucoup notamment va beaucoup certains
dans les grands médias y compris une
journée qui s'appelle Judic Miller
qui
a transmis les pièces et que les pièces
montées
donc certains médias ont contribué moi
je crois pas que l'ensemble la plupart
des médias ils ont quand même dénoncé
les mensonges américains
c'est pas les médias qu'on fait les
fausses pièces
c'est
la CIA etc et devant Colin Powell
qui je crois la portée sur sa conscience
pour le reste de sa vie
et moi je suis pas un spécialiste de
géopolitique mais enfin cette guerre
était pas justifiée en tout cas au
regard des raisons invoquées
et nos services de renseignement
je pense de la France d'avoir cette
position
[Musique]
mais
le fait que ça a été une démocratie qui
attaquée une dictature parce que
franchement le régime de ces de la Mucem
c'est pas joli
ne change pas tout à l'affaire
là on est pas tout à fait dans la même
situation on est dans un régime
autoritaire catacline démocratie
qu'invoque parce que c'est une
démocratie
parfait c'est d'ailleurs en termes
d'image voilà il était élu et mais et
donc
alors qu'est-ce qu'il en porte dans
l'esprit de Vladimir Poutine des
questions de sécurité ou de la crainte
de la propagation démocratique moi je
n'en sais rien en tout cas
c'est quand même très à faire
ont été là-bas tu dormais où alors moi
j'ai fait un aller-retour parce que je
devais revenir à Paris donc j'y suis
allé pour ouvrir le centre de le livre
qui est cette ville de l'ouest qu'une
nuit extraordinaire moi j'ai découvert
une ville franchement je suis sortie
hépaté qui me dit magnifique qui est une
ville intellectuelle capitale avec
Cracovie de l'anciennes province de
Galicie
je reparlerai quand tu demandes toujours
la question sur les trois bouquins à la
fin
ça fait partie des mythes de thinkerview
non il y a mon premier bouquin il sera
sur un bouquin sur le vive qui est
extraordinaire mais c'est pour plus tard
j'adore lire et on a une communauté qui
dévore les livres
qui est top et que j'avais commencé à
lire avant de songer qu'un jour Gérald
vive
tu dormais où t'as pas dormi j'ai pas
dormi
nous on a ouvert un centre dans
l'urgence parce que autant les grands
reporters il y en a près de 2000 sur un
crédités quand j'ai entendu j'ai pas
vérifié moi-même mais les médias
rapportent qu'il y a 2000 journalistes à
crédité étrangers en Ukraine
mais eux généralement
à part ceux qui ont oublié de le faire
et qui ont tort ils sont entraînés soit
ils étaient expérimentés avant soit ils
ont suivi des formations soit ils ont du
matériel
ce qui est pas le cas des joueurs des
journalistes Ukrainiens que ont venu ont
vu la guerre venir à eux ils sont pas
allés à la guerre elle est venue à eux
et aujourd'hui la couverture
chiffrée peut-être approximatif mais on
me donnait ça l'autre jour la couverture
médiatique en Ukraine évidemment à 80%
sur la guerre
donc en fait des gens qui n'étaient pas
du tout reporteur de guerre se sont
improvisés reporter de guerre et c'est
pour ça qu'on y allait pour les aider
pour leur dispenser du leur distribuer
du matériel des casques digelets par
balles on a commencé modestement la
première semaine
pour certains d'entre eux pas tous mais
se procurer des marchés par des se
procurer des casques et des gilets
pare-balles en ce moment y compris
partout en Europe et au-delà c'est pas
facile parce que le marché il est
vraiment saturé et là c'est pas des
façons polices il faut des catégories 4
qui puisse se porter des tiers de Kalash
c'est pas juste pour des pistolets 20
kilos 25 kg
non je pense qu'on le fait plutôt dans
les 13 kg me semble-t-il
donc c'est pour ça qu'on a commencé par
un stock modeste et puis là on est en
train de monter en puissance on en
trouve parce que aussi c'est possible
d'en trouver pendant trois mois six mois
mais
les tarifs les gilets ils nous coûtent
ou les achète à peu près je voudrais pas
influencé trop le marché mais à 1200300
euros pièce avec
je sais pas comment sont les derniers
mais je disais il faut des collerette et
la colère
il faut qu'il soit bleu
parce que c'est vrai que si c'est du
matériel sorti de stock militaire ça va
donc
il y a ça des trousses de survie
pour se faire des carreaux des enfin
tout le matériel de trousse de survie
plus
dispenser des formations et on a
dispensé une première formation je sais
plus c'est aujourd'hui ou hier mais là
on a commencé modeste aussi on a
commencé avec 8 journalistes et on va
monter en puissance il y a quand même
fallu l'installer centre il y a des
enjeux pour faire passer
des vieux journalistes c'est alors je ne
sais pas qui était le formateur là parce
qu'on est quand même une grande équipe
maintenant donc je mais pardon combien
de personnes chez RSF en tout il y a une
sorte il y a 100 salariés mais on fait
travailler des prestataires extérieurs
sur des choses comme ça
tu m'as déjà posé la question la
première fois mais je peux leur dire
vraiment faut le redire à chaque fois
c'est le c'est la manière de payer j'ai
pas je suis légèrement au dessus de 5000
lettres
voilà moi comme ça
aux formations et
il fallait donc
faire sa vie parce qu'il y a un besoin
et moi je dois dire que même les
rédactions les grandes rédactions
européennes nous ont demandé des casques
je les par balles je sais pas par
exemple les grandes rédactions
françaises elles ont à peu près chacune
25 personnes sur le terrain et même
elles en manque alors là nous on donne
prioritairement et j'ai vu pas mal de
journalistes qui sont partis là-bas en
disant j'en trouverai là-bas là on a une
espèce de frustration parce qu'on
n'arrive pas à fournir tout le monde
maintenant
pas tout de suite je pense qu'on y
arrivera mais voilà faut le temps de
faut les trouver les stocks
est-ce que tu as vu cette journaliste
qui est a débarqué sur un plateau télé
l'équivalent du journaliste
absolument mais beaucoup de médias ont
dit qu'elle était journaliste
elle est productrice elle a débarqué
avec sa pancarte
Emmanuel Macron lui propose l'asile tout
de suite
tu sais ce que je vais te poser comme
question derrière non
giulianassonge Édouard j'avais pensé
avant de venir j'avais pensé que tu me
poserais tu ferais le lien
pourquoi Macron n'a pas brandi les temps
d'art de
on va accueillir un songe ou Snowden
tout de suite c'est c'est quoi c'est on
a peur des Américains on n'a pas peur
des Russes inversement qu'est-ce qui se
passe
il est possible que la peur des
Américains soit forte et c'est même
probable
moi je me souviens d'un
l'ancien candidat à la présidentielle je
sais pas son nom c'est pas Macron qui un
jour à qui j'ai posé la question un jour
et qui m'a dit moi écoutez à titre
personnel
puis je voudrais défendre à songe mais
si un jour je suis élu je ferai jamais
parce que sinon on s'en prendra trop
plein la gueule des États-Unis
un homme politique de premier plan
je ne donnerai aucun élément distinctif
et je ne donnerai pas son salaire que je
ne connais pas
donc ça c'est la première c'est possible
même si elle brexit c'est un pays
européen avec une justice indépendante
je pense que et ça n'est pas un pays
avec le enfin nous ne sommes pas en
guerre quand je dis nous Français avec
la Russie mais il y a quand même un
conflit très fort et je pense que ça
change la donne on dirait économique
alors on peut parler d'assurance parce
que je sais mais SF est vraiment
l'organisation qu'il a le plus défendu
il y a la campagne vous avez pris
position à chaque fois on a subi toutes
les audiences
le
alors elle pourquoi il l'a fait
elle a c'est un acte de résistance assez
ou en avoir assez juste parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui a servi la propagande du
régiment son acte il est pas
journalistique c'est pas elle a pas fait
du journaliste en faisant ça elle a fait
de la protestation politique
moi j'étais surpris je dois avouer
j'étais convaincu qu'on allait pas la
revoir de sitôt
pourquoi
parce que quand on connaît le ce qui
peut comment on peut taper sur la tête
de certains en Russie je pensais qu'elle
allait rester assez longtemps on ne
retrouve revoir la lumière du jour
si
la lumière du jour comme quoi il faut
jamais prédire l'avenir je me serais
trompé si j'avais pris du public
publiquement
pourquoi cette clémence moi j'ai deux
hypothèses la pression médiatique alors
oui je pense qu'elle a pression
médiatique même si honnêtement ça
saurait si Poutine était intimidé par la
pression médiatique et par l'image
internationale
mais là peut-être que dans ce contexte
le Kremlin c'est dit bon il va y avoir
une cristallisation elle va passer pour
une figure héroïque à l'étranger ça va
se critaliser là-dessus et parfois un
cas d'une personne et même des études
cognitives où parfois il vaut mieux
défendre une personne que que 5 ça a
plus d'impact
et ils sont peut-être dit là si on est
clément
à court terme parce qu'on sait pas ce
que ce sera long terme il peut toujours
y avoir la possibilité pénale les 15 ans
de prison et ça elle a pas du tout
échapper là c'est une procédure
administrative
ça permettra que en disant regardez
c'est pas de la répression la preuve on
est on est clément voire faible
ouais enfin donc ça je pense qu'il y a
le côté coup de com ou volonté de
désamorcer pour que ça soit ça devienne
pas un abcès
et deux ça bouge quand même assez il y a
des troubles quand même dans les dans
les rédactions des médias de propagande
russe c'est quand même beaucoup de gens
qui jusqu'à présent on fait ça sans son
accommoder et qu'il a
sont perturbés et peut-être que le
Kremlin a voulu c'est des hypothèses
parce que je n'ai pas d'informations sur
le sujet mais que le Kremlin a voulu
éviter que ça en fasse une figure de
martyr qui incite d'autres à passer à
l'acte et et finalement ça n'entraîne
c'est comme dans les manifestations si
on tire sur un manifestant tout le monde
a envie d'avancer
alors que s'il pleut
quand tu tiens sur un manifestant en
général ça s'appelle les techniques
contraintes sur actionnelle on l'a vu en
Égypte
il s'amusait à tirer dans la tête des
gens pour les calmer pour faire des
martyrs se faire des blessés parce que
comme ça ça dissuade tout le monde
d'aller manifester de fouilles
différentes tu as des réactions de foule
aussi qui sont issus
c'est aussi des choses qui peuvent
radicaliser et renforcer la violence et
il arrive il y a d'ailleurs une telle
selon laquelle la pluie fait plus partir
les manifestants que les balles bien
entendu
la plus belle aussi
la couverture des gilets jaunes en
France quand il y a eu le phénomène
gilet jaune est-ce que tu penses que la
couverture médiatique est journalistique
sur comment expliquer le mouvement
pourquoi ils allaient dans la rue au
lieu de les traiter de tous les noms
pour les discréditer même si c'était il
y a peut-être deux heures tu te souviens
parce que déjà au début sur l'année la
préférence pour les événements
je pense que c'est symptomatique de ça
c'est et on peut tous être victime ça on
préfère toujours le choc là où ce qui
est visible
avec d'ailleurs sur le traitement par
exemple les chaînes tout info il y a eu
des critiques complètement divergentes
ceux qui disaient les chaînes tout info
montrent toujours les montres les gilets
jaunes partout même quand ils sont pas
très nombreux et ça les renforce et ceux
qui à l'inverse disaient plutôt côté
gilet jaune
on nous montre que la violence et on ne
se reconnaît pas là-dedans les deux
étant peut-être juste d'ailleurs
donc le fait la focalisation sur
l'événement l'accident l'acte violent
qui provoque toujours de la fascination
empêche d'aller voir ce qu'il y a
derrière et ça c'est toujours un tort de
ne pas aller voir ce qu'il y a derrière
confiance
dans quoi sur ta profession
la parole en tant que citoyen
journaliste moi je suis confirmé quand
tu t'endors le soir tu penses à quoi
heureusement je ne pense pas qu'au
journaliste quand je m'endors pourquoi
même si je pense beaucoup parce que je
travaille sur ces questions de
démocratie de matrice mais
est-ce que ça t'arrive de t'endormir pas
sous c'était une question provocatrice
est-ce que on a noté alors ça c'est
attends il y a une caméraman qui parle
on a remarqué qu'il y avait quand même
beaucoup de journalistes
qui tétine un peu est-ce que c'est parce
que le métier est difficile
il y en a qui ça donnait du talent
autrefois ils avaient une plume alerte
il y avait des des journalistes célèbres
qui a une plus complètement déliée et
qui parfois était pas tous comme
Bukowski c'était écrit
un jour alcoolisé chez pivot mais
non mais
là où il y a de la tension il y a
éventuellement des éléments et donc il y
a une mais je suis pas certain que les
journalistes boivent plus que
ou ce drogue plus que c'est pas une
maladie professionnelle
en tout cas je sais pas d'étude qui sont
non mais c'est c'est jouer un peu
provoque mais à force d'être dans la
guerre
dans des devoirs des gens qui se font
bombarder est-ce qu'il y a des stress
post-traumatiques chez les journalistes
alors cher porteur de guerre il y en a
l'un d'entre eux a écrit un très beau
livre qui s'appelle
sembler sur apparente je crois
et pendant longtemps les reporters de
guerre
ils parlaient pas de ça
parce que la figure de reportage de
guerre c'est uniquement je suis un
costaud
je vais encore plus au front que les
autres etc mais
la parole se libère sur ces questions-là
et
c'est vrai que le grand risque c'est de
ne pas voir ces toujours à des mystères
de la psychologie c'est de ne pas voir
ses propres blessures et donc c'est des
sujets sur lesquels il faut travailler
est-ce que tu veux rajouter des éléments
sur le crâne
est-ce que tu as parle tu étais sur
place raconte un peu
sur l'Ukraine j'ai pas vu toutes les
crèmes j'ai vu
la frontière la route qui va vivre avant
avant les bombardements
à la veille la veille
Poutine a eu l'élégance d'attendre que
je sorte
il faut le remarquer
et là ils ont beaucoup plus bombardé
puisque ce matin ils ont bombardé
l'aéroport ça se rapproche l'objectif
militaire classique moi je voyais
vivre c'est une ville où moi ce qui m'a
beaucoup marqué c'est comment les
habitants protègent leur ville et
comment sur les églises pour protéger
les vitraux on a mis des grands panneaux
de bois comment toutes les statues
absolument toutes les statues qui sont
impactés dans toute la ville il y a
beaucoup de statues
une vie à peu près normale
et une attente et l'espérance que non
mais nous on sera pas bombardé bien non
pas jusque là
[Musique]
ils ont une histoire un peu compliqué
qu'est-ce que tu penses de la rue
sophobie ambiante
je sais pas s'il y a une rue
moi alors dans le discours je vais pas
beaucoup sur les réseaux sociaux en ce
moment j'ai pas le temps
dans les médias j'ai pas entendu
de propos que ce soit les Russes sont
comme ça
ne sont pas
favorables c'est peut-être normal
Vladimir Poutine et au régime mais j'ai
pas entendu dans mon milieu dans les
gens que je fréquente enfin je faisais
différents j'ai jamais entendu profond
je sais pour en avoir parlé avec des
journalistes russes en exil qui sont
hyper peur de la rue
voilà mais moi j'avais pas plus à dire
c'est rien de plus
sur le fait que mon Panisse les charrus
des expositions de chats est-ce que tu
as un avis sur le fait qu'on interdise
les artistes quoi les chars une
conséquence indirecte des sanctions
j'imagine qu'il y a pas qu'on n'a pas
dit un jour on Balit les chars russes
les les
artistes russes quand on annule des
concerts quand on annule tout ça
c'est normal c'est pas normal
les sportifs alors mis à part les
sportifs radicalisés avec des signaux
ostentatoires de soutien à la guerre
mais qu'est-ce que tu en penses
est-ce que c'est ici une façon c'est pas
pour la même question je d'abord j'ai
pas particulièrement réfléchi à cette
question
l'Europe se trouve dans une situation où
elle veut
donner de l'argent pour envoyer des
armes elle veut pas se battre bien par
proxy guerre par proxy de peur de
déclencher une attaque nucléaire
je pense de mon point de vue qu'elle est
sur une position qui n'a pas tellement
d'autres
après l'application du régime de
sanctions jusqu'au il doit aller c'est
extrêmement compliqué et évidemment
qu'un régime de sanction
ça ne fait pas que des victimes justes
mais
est-ce que c'est possible de faire mieux
j'en sais rien
ce que tu veux qu'on parle d'autre sujet
est-ce que tu as un sujet je dois dire
j'étais un peu déçu par un artiste russe
qu'un pianiste Boris vski j'ai vu un
jour en concert que j'avais adoré qu'il
a tenu des propos alors lui-même les a
retirés en partie mais
qui trouvait que l'armée russe était
trop
assez violentes
en Ukraine voilà je lui mets un peu déçu
et compliqué
la violence c'est la force des faibles
et commence où s'arrête les
connaissances
dramatique 21e siècle une guerre aux
portes de l'Europe a assez combien
d'heures de vol Kiev 3h
tu veux aborder
une autre image la
l'Ouest l'Ukraine est à 15 heures de
voiture
partant avec sa voiture aussi si je
conduis c'est 30 heures c'est pas
qu'elle
anecdote pour rentrer en Ukraine en
effet dans une voiture depuis Varsovie
avec mes collègues et qui ne dépassait
pas 70 sur l'autoroute donc j'ai fait
j'ai fait ce genre là
ukrainiennes soient pas très contentes
de recevoir les journalistes qui ont été
en face du côté russe
il y a une méfiance il y a une méfiance
des autorités ukrainiennes sur
la possibilité d'infiltration
il y a toujours un risque et compris
évidemment du côté ukrainien qu'on
empêche les journalistes d'aller faire
leur travail y compris au nom de leur
propre sécurité
c'est pas un pouvoir de décider à la
place des journalistes qui doit aller où
je
évidemment que l'idéal c'est que les
journalistes puissent aller d'un côté et
de l'autre
mais deviennent de plus en plus
difficile de distinguer qui est
journaliste et qui ne l'est pas et donc
voilà je
j'ai pas suffisamment regardé le dossier
pour faire une réponse généralement RSF
parfois on commente les choses tard et
parce qu'on vérifie avant et qu'on
essaie d'être un peu rigoureux plutôt
que de faire des le temps long c'est ce
qui est le plus important
d'autres sujets que tu veux aborder
sur la presse l'Ukraine la guerre des
joyeuses thés de la vie profite
de surveillance tu veux
ah non tu disais ça
des nouvelles bah nous on a créé une
nouvelle institution du 21e siècle dans
le verre
démocratie
comme vraiment nos systèmes juridiques
qui sont plus adaptés font d'inventer de
nouveau que c'est pas juste en faisant
appel au juriste qui rappelle le système
du passé en fait faut faire appel des
gens différents dans des pays différents
et aujourd'hui nos parlements sont pas
tellement équipés pour ça surtout
d'ailleurs en France où il y a même pas
eu de commissions parlementaires sur le
sujet alors que ça aurait pu permettre
de convoquer des gens de faire un
narratif de mieux comprendre
et donc nous on a créé un organe
d'application
du partenariat dont je parlais des 45
États mais qui dirigé par la société
civile qui s'appelle forum sur la
formation démographique
et qui réunit des groupes de travail
avec des sommités partout dans le monde
et qui là vient de lancer
un projet de GIEC l'équivalent du GIEC
m'a appliquait au cas où informationnel
ce que le GIEC qui parle mais personne
les écoute oh tu peux dire
personnellement
tout le monde s'en fout pas enfin
regardons la préoccupation je crois que
c'est le deuxième sujet de préoccupation
après le pouvoir d'achat ou avant
c'est qu'un sujet après comment on agit
ça c'est autre chose comment on agit
dans un système de concurrence entrée
thêta mais ça veut dire que les choses
sont pas oui et puis tout à l'heure
c'est quelque chose j'ai pas relevé ou
tu laisses penser que les journalistes
parlaient pas de ça on peut pas dire que
les gens ils se parlent pas du
réchauffement climatique
non j'ai pas compris mais donc ils en
parlent la question c'est après comment
on agit mais ça j'en ai ils sont pas
responsables de tout franchement
que chacun est collectivement se regarde
le chaos informationnel
le risque de perte de contrôle
technologique c'est l'autre grande
menace pour l'humanité alors là je vais
être négatif pour le coup je
contre la négativité mais il y a un
sujet sur lequel il faut attirer
l'attention
c'est l'autre grande menace pour
l'humanité et pour chacun d'entre nous
avec le réchauffement climatique
pour l'anecdote j'ai eu un rendez-vous
avec Anthonio ducouteras le secrétaire
général des Nations unies début décembre
on a parlé ces sujets là y compris de
chochanatsu BOV du capitalisme
surveillance qu'il venait de lire
discuter avant l'émission ah oui mais
qu'il venait de lire ce bouquin de 700
pages c'est roboratif
écoutez RS
accompagnant me dit en fait à mon sens
et je le raconte il y a une menace
encore plus grande que le réchauffement
climatique c'est l'intelligence
artificielle
tout ça peut nous échapper
et alors
nous échapper c'est à dire que
échapper au contrôle démocratique
échapper
c'est donner du pouvoir à un seul homme
un seul groupe qui pourra imposer
s'imposer donc moi je trouve ça très
légitime et il faut qu'on s'intéresse à
toutes les questions démocratiques de
comment améliorer la démocratie de quoi
il y a des choses
tout ça peut être des débats secondaires
par rapport à ce qui peut se passer
et d'ailleurs le piège dans lequel on se
retrouve c'est qu'il faut qu'on ait plus
de démocratie pour arriver à résoudre
ces sujets-là pour que tout le monde se
sente mobilisé enfin on est dans des
espèces de pièges donc il faut arriver à
sortir
et donc pour répondre à ce qui est un
peu l'équivalent de la menace climatique
par exemple quand la menace climatique
il faut résoudre les causes il suffit
pas d'acheter des climatiseurs et des
données à tout le monde c'est pas comme
ça qu'on va s'en sortir sur le carré
formationnel c'est la même chose
l'équivalent des chaos des climatiseurs
c'est les lois de contenu qui se
balorent en bas on va tel contenu qui
est dangereux on va l'évacuer tout ça
c'est la même chose ça je pense que ça
marche pas il y a eu des tentatives de
loi en Allemagne en France ailleurs
c'est pas opérant donc il faut aller au
cœur du système
et pour ça
on a initié et ça c'est vraiment un
volontarisme d'organisation si je peux
dire un processus qui est un peu
semblable au processus climatique des
cops équivalent des Conférences des
Parties donc on a obtenu que ces états
ces 45 états chaque année il fasse un
sommet sur la formation à la démocratie
il se réunissent pour l'instant c'est au
niveau des Affaires étrangères là on est
en train de créer des comités techniques
pour entrer vraiment dans le dur du
travail 2 il faut un GIEC donc là on est
en train de créer l'Observatoire sur la
formation démocratie j'avais une réunion
sur le sujet aujourd'hui
on a nommé des comités de pilotage les
deux personnes qui dirigent c'est
chochanat subof qui est cet université
américaine qui a écrit le grand livre
c'est un peu l'équivalent du capital
sur ces questions
et donc le capitalisme surveillance
l'âge du capitalisme platurien sera
exactement son titre et Angel gouria qui
est l'ancien secrétaire général de
l'OCDE et à l'intérieur il y a par
exemple Maria RSA avec qui on a beaucoup
travaillé qui est avec Dimitri moratov
le prix Nobel de la Paix cette année
c'est Maria qui est une journée Philippe
depuis le début de cette initiative on
travaille avec là depuis le premier jour
donc on est en train de créer le GIEC et
l'idée c'est qu'il soit prêt là on est
dans le groupe de préfiguration
on fait des recommandations aux États
on crée cette coalition démocratie bref
et la seule différence avec le
réchauffement climatique c'est que le
réchauffement climatique font en parler
avec Pékin avec Moscou avec là sur la
démocratie on va pas aller chercher le
dénominateur commun avec Pékin donc
c'est du multilatéralisme plus restreint
je pense la dernière fois que j'y suis
allé c'est juste au moment où j'étais
nommé RSF pour faire un livre et puis je
me suis pu retourner
et donc il y a des possibilités
maintenant c'est comme sur le
réchauffement climatique faut de la
volonté et il suffit pas de volonté
politique c'est toujours facile en fait
de dire il faut de la volonté des
politiques non faut de la volonté de la
société parce que c'est la société qui
peut travailler politique et les
politiques s'ils ont fait ça tout seul
les gens leur gueule reites-tu
donc on a intérêt à vite comprendre ces
sujets là qui pour l'instant
et de ce point de vue là les évidemment
que les médias ils ont une
responsabilité de pas intéresser à des
choses dérisoires et moi je pense que
l'un des grands effets positifs du
nouvel agencement de
nouvelles systèmes de l'espace informel
c'est qu'on s'intéresse plus qu'avant
paradoxalement aux effets de 6 alors il
y a tout le champ du divertissement de
la consommation des influenceurs de tous
ces contenus corrompus qui de mon point
de vue est un truc désastreux mais il y
a aussi plus de gens qui s'intéressent
aux effets de système à des choses plus
complexes et qui prennent le temps tu
fais comment pour protéger toi
numériquement des gouvernements écoute
ça dépend ton téléphone
pas récemment mais faire Pegasus tu l'as
fait audité alors on a regardé si
j'étais j'ai vérifié si j'étais sur le
livre Pegasus j'ai fait extrêmement vexé
mais non tu as fait édité ton téléphone
moi je fais
[Musique]
pourtant je suis allé avec mon enfin
alors à chaque fois que je pars dans un
pays vraiment un jour
on a fait une mission confidentielle en
Arabie qu'on a rendu public après
c'était après l'assassinat de Shogi je
te raconte pas toute l'histoire mais
après l'assassinatrice qui a fini au
mixeur dans une ambassade en Turquie ça
a découper la scie à house plus
exactement s'il faut entrer dans les
détails
vraiment dans les détails non le mec il
est 6h
les bandes qu'ils ont sorties c'était
quand même terrifiants
le mec il mettait sa musique dans les
oreilles
dramatique et
on est allé pour essayer de négocier des
libérations de journalistes en disant là
vous avez un vrai dommage d'image
maintenant seul moyen de vous remonter
c'est de libérer les journalistes il y
avait 34 ans c'est négocié c'est
négociations malheureusement n'ont pas
porté leurs fruits mais enfin qui ne
tente rien n'a rien en tout cas on s'est
pas compromis et là évidemment qu'on y
va avec que du matériel propre
et en utilisant VPN plus application
cryptée
[Musique]
je me le noter pour la prochaine fois
chiffré et
[Musique]
donc voilà j'adapte la sécurité aux
enjeux
j'ai des formations là on a beaucoup
fait on a été assez pionnier sur les
questions de formation à la sécurité
numérique maintenant c'est plus
généralisé donc paradoxalement n'en fait
moins parce que il y a plus de
prestataires partout mais mais
effectivement c'est un enjeu moi j'ai
encore des journalistes là qui m'ont
appelé on a notre section allemande donc
notre bureau à Berlin a un bureau
helpdesk un bureau de soutien numérique
en termes d'outils et de formation
tu as des sujets que tu veux encore
aborder
je crois qu'on a quand même déjà
beaucoup parlé ça fait combien de temps
là
ça fait deux heures et 26 minutes
trois bouquins tu la connais cette
question là ouais je me suis préparé
et le premier en revanche c'est pas ce
que je veux dire n'est pas artificielle
j'ai commencé un bouquin il y a quelques
mois et bon je lis plusieurs bouquins la
femme cassé qui s'appelle retour à
Lemberg
Lemberg c'est le moinement pour cette
ville qui s'appelle veuve en polonais je
crois en russe qui s'appelle vive la
ville de l'Ouest dont on a beaucoup
parlé
c'est un grand juriste international je
crois qu'il est franco-britannique mais
il me semble qu'il y a dû écrire en
anglais qui s'appelle Philippe Sands
qui est dans la famille était originaire
de là-bas
et qui s'est rendu compte que deux
grands juristes du 20e siècle était au
Russie originaire de là il y avait
enseigné à l'université là-bas
1 qui s'appelle Hersch Lauter Park qui
s'appelle Raphaël
qui était d'ailleurs opposé parce qu'ils
avaient des visions très différentes des
grands crimes internationaux faire des
grands crimes à l'échelle de l'humanité
il y en a un qui partit de l'individu
et qui a été l'inventeur du crime contre
l'humanité
c'est la hauteur parte l'autre a fait
Lemkin
il est parti de la communauté il a porté
le crime de génocide et ça s'est
retrouvé
deuxième alors ça peut être
l'âge du capitalisme turion 700 pages
info faut y aller c'est mais qui est sûr
le capitalisme surveillance c'est un
capitalisme qui
et financer sur la base des prédictions
sur nos comportements futurs et non
seulement des prédictions mais qui finit
par orienter nos comportements futurs
elle est forte je suis heureux de
travailler avec elle c'est une femme
extraordinaire ça alors quand on la voit
devant un responsable tout ça elle va
pas de ma morte c'est de l'université
engagé j'aurais pu citer je crois que
j'avais cité la dernière fois mais donc
je le fais vite mais moi c'est le livre
de mes 15 dernières années la fin de
l'homme rouge
Nobel de littérature Belarus qui est
maintenant je crois en exil à Berlin et
qui raconte
qui fait prendre de prendre conscience
de ce que peut être le traumatisme russe
et la fin de l'homme rouge est notamment
ces années
où les tragédies ont été vécues au nom
d'idéos et puis là il y a l'argent dans
les années 90 qui l'emporte
et en fait toutes ces tragédie perdent
encore plus de leur sens et le drame
russe je trouve de mon point de vue n'a
jamais été aussi bien des criques dans
ce bouquin c'est une ancienne
journaliste
voilà ça fait trois et puis sinon bah il
y a la matrice
alors tu veux appeler Pierre Bellemare
là
voilà
c'est que l'un des effets pour toutes
les nous savons pour les albums photos
qu'on publiait RSF le prix du papier
augmenté
est-ce que tu peux ouvrir une page et
nous liens à vous un mot
je tombe sur Google News j'en ai un
autre non
plus brutal
un endroit où j'ai dit
en s'inspirant de Chirac nous ne pouvons
pas attendre que le terrain démocratique
brûle démocratique brûle évidemment
inspiré du discours de Johannesburg la
maison brûle et nous regardons
d'ailleurs
il faut éteindre l'incendie avant qu'il
ne s'étendent un conseil pour les jeunes
générations
bouteille à la mer generation de
journaliste ou jeune génération tout
court alors je me génération tout court
et jeunes génération de journalistes
[Musique]
il y avait le conseil de
Stéphane Hessel indignez-vous moi je
dirais vous mais agissez
et franchement c'est facile de
s'habiller il faut quand même mieux agir
pour les journalistes c'est des fois
c'est difficile de s'indigner
surtout quand c'est plus l'action que
l'animation l'action sort du reste c'est
tellement facile s'indigner par un clic
par un
slactiviste et
on n'a pas fait changer s'arrêter au
symbolique ça n'a aucun enfin ça n'a
aucun intérêt c'est mieux on est du bon
côté des valeurs mais
il faut d'abord faire changer les choses
et pour les jeunes génération de
journalistes moi j'entends beaucoup des
des directeurs d'écoles de journaliste
etc maintenant que en fait ou des
rédactions alors je veux pas faire le
vieux con moi je dirais une école j'ai
adoré travailler ces étudiants qui
étaient franchement le côté le niveau
baisse à ce niveau là c'était pas vrai
mais j'entends qu'il y a une moindre
envie d'aller voir de partir en
reportage quand on dit tiens qui veut
partir là-bas non non mais alors tu
viens de faire ce geste je transcris
pour l'hiver
il y a évidemment le fait que dans plein
de rédactions on veut moins envoyer les
gens mais le phénomène maintenant c'est
attirer un poste de correspondant qui se
trouve dans tel pays ou tu pourrais
partir en reportage là
la chance c'est quand même d'aller voir
d'abord ce qui se passe
histoire merci
[Musique]